une production du studio sf mais elle
n'ose en fils présenté par caisse mille
podcast on parle de ce qu'ont vécu nos
invités dates ci dessus ph quand tu es
avec moi d'hommes plan de vous on veut
sensibiliser les gens à la santé mentale
ou à discuter de la santé mentale c'est
pourquoi qu'est smi ont lancé en
collaboration avec une artiste
montréalaise doctorante en psycho trois
nouveaux étuis donc à chaque étui en
fait les cinq dollars qui va aller à la
fondation canadienne de la santé mentale
puis vous avez aussi recevoir dans
chacune de vos commandes un psy carton
avec des dépenses est positive pour vous
aider
dans votre vie en fait au quotidien fait
qu'ils allaient voir les études sont
vraiment vote à partir du 8 juillet fait
qu'ils sont en vente maintenant jusqu'au
2 septembre effectué à les voir utiliser
un code promo sans filtre 20 pour 20% de
rabais sur toutes vos commandes kiss me
sinon cette semaine dans cette semaine
file droit file droit humoriste et
personnalités québécoises incroyable
animateurs animateurs et nouvellement on
a parlé de paternité
son impact est inclus puis s'était pas
encore fait du moins annoncer mais le
gibus que ces réseaux sociaux qui là tu
as un petit bd dont on utilise et on
espère le temps de discuter avec lui
damas il est drôle il est fin il est fun
parler de toutes sortes d'affaires comme
[Musique]
comme quoi comme je vais le découvrir en
écoute ici son premier son premier guide
du mort avec ces compagnies sont une
compagnie qu'on est bien ici au centre
incroyablement qui sans cette histoire
de l'écrit le palais aussi des communs
qu'égérie sa pandémie qui fait beaucoup
d'encre virtuelle puis les lieux enfin
évidemment il peut recommencer à faire
des shows en personne et on parlait
aussi vers la fin de l'enquêté de
d'anxiété de ces problèmes de stress
d'anxiété puis d'humeur aussi que celui
causé sur le milieu professionnel qu'il
ait fallu qu'il y ait un petit prise de
conscience après avoir attendu film
parlait de ce super récepteurs sans
cesse pas touchant aussi qui sauve comme
ce fait on le remercie vraiment donc bon
pas de casse bonne écoute qui ont sans
me voir nos sponsors j'ai recommencé le
vote d'aujourd'hui est présenté par walt
de rieux qui fait de la nourriture pour
chien de la nourriture innovante de la
nourriture à la fine pointe des
technologies alors que ce soit pour
votre petit pitou tout use pour votre
gros colosse ils vont adorer la
nourriture doit mieux c'est une
compagnie éco-responsable en plus mais
ils font leurs gâterie à base de
protéine alternative comme les gâteries
à base des grillons solide huyon les
chiens capote là dessus en veulent et en
redemande
ces malades des grillons pour lui il
faut aussi des galeries à base de pulpe
de fruits travers collaboration entre la
compagnie look donc loupé extrait leur
jus des fruits qui sont délaissés par
l'industrie ensuite ils filment leurs
pulls à warwick yeux font des gâteries
pour les chiens fondé de la nourriture à
base d'insectes
il fonde la nourriture à base de carpe
asiatique est un poisson qui doit être
pêchés pour conserver les fonds marins
donc tout ça est fait de façon super éco
responsable puis pour vous qui avez
acheté un
bien un chiot pendant la pandémie pour
sentir moins seul chez vous mais font
une nouvelle gamme de nourriture
seulement pour les chiens donc
spécialement conçu pour beauty pitou
d'amour on a un complément aux autres
esf 20 pour 20% de rabais aux sur leur
site web mon chien sauve le monde point
ca fait aller voir sa pire votre chien
va adorer puis vous n'allez pas le
regretter
avec merci la garderie le podcast de
cette semaine et présenté par nos amis
chez mindscape vous les connaissez ce
sont les meilleurs produits pour
l'entretien sous la ceinture
ils viennent tout juste de lancer le
perfect package 4.0 vous nous aviez
entendu parler du 3.0 mais laisse les
4.0 qui vient avec le land mort 4.0 donc
les mêmes caractéristiques que le
lendemain ou 3.0 c'est à dire la
technologie anti un nid cage de boys 3-2
prouve la flash lite tout le kit mais en
plus ça vient avec des gardes
si vous voulez par exemple vous tailler
la barbe avec des différentes longueurs
vous taillez sous la ceinture
littéralement avec différentes longueurs
ça vient avec un travaux locke donc ça
empêche de partir dans vos valises dans
le perfect package 4.0 il y aussi le
croient plus vive à y redire c'est un
prix qui rafraîchit
cette zone là qui est aussi le clou
après heureux qui est un des hauts
dirigeants ça vient avec des boxeurs qui
empêche les poils incarnés donc pas de
frottement désagréable après orangeois
c'est vraiment le package ultime pour
n'importe qui dans votre entourage que
des bijoux de famille en fête qui ont un
code promo pour vous autres et le
sans-fil dhr en un mot pour 20% de
rabais et le shipping gratuit donc 20%
de rabais le shipping gratuit
c'est non négligeable allez voir ce
puits assurez vous d'utiliser un code
promo comme c'est mon sa mort que c'est
nous qui vous envoie merci mme skate
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression qu'ils n'ont acquis
plus actif que l'autre celui de te faire
dire des bêtises dans ce que tu fais
puis on veut travailler avec toi ceci ça
s'étripe m et ouais de faire comme moi
aime te faire reconnaître dans la
société si c'est un peu de la marque
tu deviens voit groix seul à wemmel tu
vois je pense c'est pas tout le monde
pense à merde que moi j'ai eu et c'est
moi j'ai fait occupation deux jeux de
stud s'y connaît un peu le background
tipi rapidement le monde ont arrêté de
me reconnaître sanctionnant rue mais
quand je suis sorti le japon ne devrait
pas lavés en haleine où le padfone tu
avais tu avais pop up ou non il ya pas
un petit bout de chou qui s'est dit en
m'inscrivant au dg c'est exactement ce
qui va m'arriver c'est l'effet harper
étant conscient d'être non bah c'est sûr
ben j'aurais dû pour poser la question
plus un peu le tir parce que j'avais
mettons que ça allait me permet d'aller
m'ouvrir des portes comme celui-ci sauf
que je sauf que charest pas que le prix
était seul
pensez pas que c'est parce que moi
mettons ces mots je te connais je
connais pas par tap ersonne public
jamais de la pratique vie je vois pas
rester calmes et ont des taux jim
désagréable mais mettons que quelqu'un
dise genre h canet paulhan cette fille
qui te kroes a été mes tantes et au
world renders mongolie 3 si quelqu'un
viendrait ici et je m'excuse de vous
déranger août y voit l'opportunité
qu'ils viennent voir mn ph frangipane
photo vite vite j'aime vraiment ce que
tu fais pinot noir ou et domaine
si c'est pas envahissant c'est peu mais
après quand la personne s'en veut je
pense qu'il est quand même un petit
sentiment hier je suis d'accord avec toi
tu es tu arrivé avec ta mère qui aime
encore lire sur gardant le sourire bien
placé deux parties qui sourit puis le la
personne et butin perron mais alors rien
c'est quelqu'un qui lit poquet l'aca
souvent les gauchos montsho générale
passé trois heures moins dramatique
cognac export sas pauvres et âme en
attaque
je crois aux probabilités qui va chier
plus que tu aimes ce pour y acheter quoi
les 105 10 j'avais pas que les prêts à
payer c'était pour ça vous autres
peut-être que j'ai exposé au bord un peu
aussi il vous force à tourner et menzah
l'élite
aillagon qui ont perdu là à la carte un
peu vieille a pas de la carte parce
qu'ils trient pas trop écouter d'abord
c'était dieu le sait comme moi je
cherchais ultime ans aurait pas des
mêmes sans savoir si j'y crois sans
savoir qu'elles vont ils cherchent eux
mais la star c'est cher mani07 heures
mais je vais faire embaucher
je me sens en faisant le sentiment de
pitié parce qu'ils étaient passés et je
me sentir mal pour lui mais recourent
déjà fait mais en même temps mais c'est
très peu et les folies comme en europe
une fois que deux buts et c'est sûrement
la question que je me repose sur le tas
si je leur ferais tu souhaites seppi il
faut que j'aie vécus shirts et cannage
pas sur tes sauf que là tu vas
activement refaire précisément la même
chose c'est vrai
je chasse ça change à chaque jour c'est
plus mon coup ils m'attendent
puisse donc oui plus mon coin peu après
ce genre voit-il tout ce que j'ai fait
ce que j'ai fait après puis je me dis ah
lemondenumerique ans maintenant pour le
podcast c'est l'fun s'affranchir des
staffeurs s'affranchir du bail parce que
vous avez le site hoffman c'est sur
cette offre
ça vote suivent un port louis mais je
pense sincèrement que mam et sa tombe
ces gens je pense pour vrai c'est une
marie mines et le team hm c'est un
concours c'est l'oubli
sauf que sam était quand même de l'avant
un talent star académie c'est sous la
porte tandis que les autres tu sais pas
vos qualités sont mis de l'avant - non
c'est bien comolli soulignons aussi que
wind fait-elle telle affaire c'est comme
si on y voit les trois les champs c'est
moi qui partent en premier sont très
élevés pour mille raisons
même si huawei apprécié drôles graves et
non pas qu'eric est avec lego beaupuy
gilbert était très bon goût j'avais pris
un plexiglas dessus
l'auteur commencé à trouver un peu avec
la fin du stage
alors où on est aujourd'hui le j'ai fait
comme une quinzaine ouais c'était un peu
plus entre 15 et 20 h au pire commencé
fin ces facteurs parce que j'ai
recommencé fin mars car comme tu le mets
ton il y avait quelques régions pin ou
habitant maintenant à montréal dans une
zone rouge et on avait le droit de
changer dit on est juste pour la job ses
fans
nous on pouvait y aller mais c'était oui
de pascal apprécié c'était chacun nos
chambres d'hôtel tout est fermé à 9h30
les premières fois on ne peut penser que
l'on sache est un super ou de la bière
ou peu importe
après je rentre dans ton aujourd'hui il
reste quoi de voir rien yat sen
indépendant mais foutrement un poste à
gaz mais il vaut porte à vendre ces
clubs brigade ou quelquefois mais pas
que c'est ce qui est après si je mens à
la québec pour ouvrir le mon horreur
c'était ses shows à québec quatre shows
à gatineau facquet les deux premières
rondes qui ont pourtant paru hier midi
québec gatineau fac il s'est passé cinq
semaines entre la reprise au saguenay
puis la reprise comme killer roule
encore accepté turf dcc difficile je
trouve des méthodes en rodage de ses
vrais amateurs de créer là dedans parce
que je joue deux fois par saivet
l'artiste août après membres
habituellement je vais aller tester
juste un numéro sa fin la semaine test
l'ensemble elle est maintenant je vais
tester juste un numéro qui joue obligé
en ime de repasser par l'ensemble il des
fois je fais que hockey et on va aller
vite c'est numéro un de trop parce qu'il
est soluble
ils vont bien plus politique et je veux
travailler la iv va être super long
masquer le quatrième numéro c'est lui je
redonne habituellement je râle et les
jus dessous le mettons dans montréal
annie morris il peut faire sans shu ça
commence
ça commençait à huawei setups a fini à
minuit
mettez le jeu vaut bordel je m'envoie au
terminal a précieusement vos ou et ou
bois
je m'en veux à un autre baby je finis au
bordel mais en mon bordel ans que mon
bordel domestique et le 5e jour de la
soirée et de mayroy ça représente lui je
présente le même numéro un mais dans une
soirée 5 crabe différence c'est fou ce
mais j'ai travaillé en full je faisais
surtout bank a racheté en rade à juin
parce que je pense qu'il faut donner
quand même les crédits je pense à
françois bellefeuille je pense est lui
qui a comme fait l'arrêt de la treille
qui faisait lui autre que ce que mou ce
qu'on m'a dit qu'il faisait pic j sans
voix sans copier ses quêtes monde un ami
de petites chaufferies
mais entre ampli chaud moi je veux pas
tu écoutais parce qu'on a eu huit
minutes je viens de faire huit minutes
faut que j'me réécoute jlg aucun moyen
en réécoutant accents religieux de fact
it temps régis avec ton sel ce plug
cliquetant 40 ton calepin tune up puis
après si tu continues tu mets risques et
c'est le fun c'est réellement en
vendrait du matin font rien
il a après tu vas réécouter émettons moi
je voir écouter 2-2 numérique gros max 2
take puis là je reprends des notes le
vendredi déjà noir wherever puis après
si c'est comme ça mais laissés en ce
moment c'est que cette oeuvre pour trait
mais c'est super le fun parce que
lorsque tu refuses monde mais canadien
maire de vente devant un public qui ont
un premier a tout changé
2500 personnes mais on dirait que ces
vingt mille personnes pourraient s je
trouvais ça plus au nord que karim est
d'aider décrite volonté exactes fax la
même chose d'insensé d'une salle ils ont
beau être des fois 120 ou défaut 250
pour reyes haricots c'est vraiment l'fun
semaine passée la musique ok j'avais qui
licencient je veux qu aucune arrière
droit qui s'appelait notre nos tristes
compositrice tant que film qui est super
cool beau projet pour travailler en
soudure en simple
bref on joue à sainte-thérèse à défendre
l'église pcc petit public le genre du
temps c'est tout ce qu'une déclarent des
plus lourdes que j'ai vu parce que le
monde totalement content de voir un show
tellement jeté comme tabarnak apprennent
tout critiquer c'est cool c'est dans le
monde on compte en tant qu on trouve
quelques manques et enfin eu du monde
enfin je vois vraiment ce qui nous
irrite ici pour l'artiste qui est
derrière qui est d'un coulisses un
jardin tu peux cinq minutes avant le
show absolument c'est minutes avant
cholet tout ce qui est en tendance assez
les discussions tout le monde j'ai dit
que ce cher comme le 15e place on est
dit on va en fou comme évident puisque
c'était tout ce qui touche au meeddat
pandémie par exemple investi des choses
virtuelles mais angie fait plus que 200
chevaux virtuel enfants soient pas mana
et du presque jour pour jour
on a commencé le 1er jour du white foil
le 27 mars 20 puis tu veux je reprenais
le 21 mars 20 21 c'était mon premier
show au saguenay a été révisée à partie
puis dans matic quand un peu comme tout
le monde on pensait que ça allait durer
deux semaines ont ce droit pour le
buffer à y faisons deux shows online qui
mouille j'avais fait des shows de rodage
de lecture de textes moi j'étais en
pleine création pleine écriture jeté
comme un molosse ces capsules c'est
quand tu sens qu'il était dedans avec
est écrit que tu trouve que ça fait du
sens visible ce puits là on t'arrête
notre éthique c'est que non mais là mais
j'ai encore du jura puis je peux pas
aller me coucher le pij peut pas
attendre
mâcon et on s'est dit j'écris j'écris
statut facebook smap al hay son venin
show online gratuit écrivez à l'adresse
gmail suivant fileront chaud au coeur
s'est adjugé point que j'en avais fait
une réponse automatisée salue ton nom
est bien inscrit on te revient avec la
date
dans ma tête il y avait chez pas le
métro top 200 personnes
on coupe la poire en deux
fait deux jours 200 personnes ça va le
fun en une heure et demie on a reçu 2500
et on est générée 2500 réponse
automatique t1 fac google nous a banni
parce qu'il pensait que tu étais un
sponsor et lors qu'il n'y a que j'écris
elle salue mon courriel marche peuple et
10 aux annonces et ça c'était trop de
trafic pour une nouvelle truc et ça
qu'on vous a bloqué on étudie votre
compte puis fait que ben non on a envie
de monter de quoi puis moi il faut que
je fasse le show t on on veut pas une
langue d'oc hampigny possiblement que ça
m'intéresse je m'aime je peux me permet
d'être seul à tangente finalement parlé
au téléphone avec les services à la
clientèle google à montréal puis l'ont
dit balance pour faire des chauffards
qui nous ont débloqué fait le sas à bari
comme à 2500 pleinement m'écrivez acquis
mls en marche peu sadique l'adresse et
et corrompu whatever works est en fait
le pilon ne reçut pour essayer 22 mille
connexions qu'on avait eues fait que ça
veut dire que les gens s'inscrivent et
haine qui ont donné le jour de noël
chaud puis moi je paye est je paye les
mots riches paient le globe qui opérait
lecam toutes les affaires birmanes est
on arrivé au mois de juillet saison
venait on venait de franchir le cap des
vingt-deux mille connexions du monde qui
revenait peuple st jacques et visser
beaucoup de monde je payais tessin mph
acquis maurice qui étaient là j'étais
comme à mende on a fait des choix en
salle le symbole tnm moyenne trace le
haut je voyais pas ça allait finalement
finalement tenu des commanditaires plein
de gens qui sont embarqués puis on a
frais la possibilité aux gens de faire
des dons soit à nous autres pour
supporter du maurice soit aux banques
alimentaires métier on est des 12500
repos atteint paribas a vraiment été une
expérience vraiment l'fun cp les jets on
est sorti du monde la pcu ou les
humoristes qui était comme ici
autant de fois par mois mais ton ben je
fais plus que 2000 p as far as cac et je
dois jouer plus après les corpos on
rentre et il est chaud pour des
entreprises puis toute l'équipe au mois
de décembre c'est 18 choc on a fait dix
huit shows corpo qu'on ait faite au mois
de décembre puisqu'ils foule c'est que
ça nous a tout ramené à quelque chose de
bain essentiel d pourquoi on fait de
l'humour ultime ans c'est pas pour faire
l'achat à l'école c'est là qu'est la
région et les pâtes rayons mais si dans
le sens où l on sait juste appliqué à
ispoure est en game dans un puits rires
non ça faisait tellement longtemps que
j'avais pas écouté tout un show
d'habitude j'arrive je fais mon numéro
chaque montant parce que je m'en vais
dans un autre c'est pas parce que je
suis autant avoir le milieu s'est passé
jusque là la halle la scène montréalaise
d'humour a tellement grossi qui fait que
avant avant on le prenait quesemand mal
si tu restais pas toute la soirée
pis asteur on se pose des questions
s'étaient pas double ou triple bouquet
star mais le savez juste ramener un gie
rien d'autre à faire à suhr j'écoute le
show je checke tout le monde puis après
sens donner des commentaires
c'était tellement l'fun c'était vraiment
de se retrouver là gagnent des tubes qui
font de l'humour ensemble parce qu'ils
aiment se faire de l'humour parce qu'ils
y ont rien d'autre dans le même lieu
physique que vous avez chacun chez vous
a star on est toutes dans le même lieu
mêmes lieux physiques mais pendant le
bourg st chacun chez soi c'est ce qui
était facteur basses castes a maintenant
une gossip monde et les lits jouer après
avoir couché ses enfants mais c'est vrai
que nous mettons tout seul chez nous là
je parle d'un mmo prochaine éviter ce
modèle est peut-être manqué comme ça lui
avez vous remarqué un chien endormi
autre chose pour ce fac et one n'a pas
chômé
un ca mais ça c'est d'avoir d'avoir des
restrictions cette force à faire des
choix créatifs comme ce puits et au
final ça va être ce qu'ils vont réussir
à continuer à rester créatif d'un an
pandémie qui vont s'en sortir le mieux
jean que pour vous aussi on parle
beaucoup la santé mentale mais de mon
travail peut s étoffe un sacrement de 13
ans c'est sûr ça a aidé d'avoir au moins
quelque chose
ma blonde est en restauration qui a
trouvé cette offre beaucoup de remises
en question à admettre finir ses études
en gestion hôtelière je pourrais ouvrir
la commencer à travailler
spears et ça a été le mois j'ai vu ce
gisi vu aller puis s'adapter à toutes
les fois des salaires que l'on veut
pouvoir ouvrir à lyon hormis aux
manigances toute la sphère au kef
d'ouvrir deux mois après c'est fini
latifi comme hayman si tu commences à
sainte croix des marchands de glace
toute l'équipe moi je vis ça allait même
se trouve et quel est leur les youyous
le cpie comme tu dis du monde qui ont
juste simplement pas pu travailler c'est
ou même de s'adapter
ça doit être les jeunes qui sont allés
qui sont à l'école s'arrête of this
d'apprendre sur zoom et imagine-t-il
preuve tu fais comme un voleur j'avais
monté un sacré plan de copan dans
l'abord du gros fun tout au long de
l'année pileux si je parlais qu'un prof
ni tué ni profit dit je me sens mal de
donner des cours sur zoom parce que
j'allais peut pas le contact je n'ai pas
le sursaut il dit je pensais vraiment un
bon prof comme à présent ciel symbole
guéthary dans nos vies ne manque en
ignorer complètement l'essentiel
en présentiel a raison mais qui fait que
mes semaines j'ai pas mes repères j'ai
pas mes enfants c'est lui il ya le
sentiment je sais pas d'échec ou j'sais
pas comment appeler ses métiers ses 45
livre pas la marchandise cesser tout ce
feeling parce que tu mets ton animé une
clarté capter l'attention maintenant
d'une clause de rands enfants puis faut
chaud du mot il est quand même des
similitudes à préparer capable de capter
le monde peut connaître show en ligne ça
doit être plutôt faux si tu avais très
feedback brown on avait un feedback et
avec un délai d'à peu près comme une
seconde main team comme tout le monde
n'importe quoi mais j'ai dressé l'été
l'été on a trouvé cette offre me sentais
mal même pour les humoristes de dire
club les camps safar bourg le monde sont
importants mais franches aux states pour
se dire qu'on arrêtait l'été passé mais
non la tension s'était c'était will pas
ce qu'est le monde était quand même
vraiment content d'avoir quelque chose à
faire mais il mène j'ai fait mon show le
devant du monde qui se baignent bâtiment
j'essaye de partir dangereux qui
réussissent à partir de fou y chauffer
ma fille est tellement il y avait mis
son servent pour qu'on le veut sur des
foires et des marchés où j'ai tourné à
gauche si ça ne rame mickey avant a été
de bâtiments mais j'étais peut-être
autant sur les yeux sur les conditions
de spectacle les chipeaux toi car tu vas
faire des choses ici c'est ici
mais bien sûr pas souvent geek brune su
parler de cabale de dire non bâti
maintenant justement capable de dire non
aux conditions bègles de thé mais
j'avoue que maintenant c'est comme je
vais aller me faire le show pareil
demain c'est lui combien carey folie se
donne pour que je viens de faire un show
sur l'heure du midi pour huit personnes
mais là j'en ai fait de même sur l'heure
du midi jean paul à oued et qu'au repos
pour une caisse desjardins ou rêveurs ou
telle affaire allait pas troubler gay ce
mariage et que t'as pas besoin de payer
de retour de son souza égouts jason vous
autres vous aimez pas c'est finalement
ces banques grecques
voici le groupe est capable de faire
formidable jusqu'à toi sur rien que tu
reviennes g2 tech je fais et le savent
c'est des fois aux autres ils disent
qu'il ya aucune personne qui valide son
génie se [ __ ] respectueux je fais
parfait fait juste plus rire pis nous
aurons un an avec deux mois qu'ils ont
un petit pad ou si c'est bon bon ça
qu'ils m'ont été pdg
comme en 4e mais les rires des gens
c'est sur le zoom qui tu veux qu'on les
a capté on n'est jamais ton n'est pas
une banque belge entre en sorte de rire
différentes captées sur 80 chevaux
maintenant
ouais faut pas faire ça fait trop fait
des soirées que cette offre ou des
soirées où met-on on a un artiste ou un
artiste qui est bambins nervures
nerveuse d'être le plus nous on veut que
ça se passe bien pour cette personne le
même châssis que son numéro vadrot
mouche déjà npo d'ici trois quatre
heures juste pour la mettre en confiance
au début pour que ces personnes ne sont
en confiance
meziane 3,4 qu'après celle des loups
c'est comme si c'était son 122e chaud
juste district jobs lui c'est en effet
la seule force et fait juste papa ni il
faut pas qu'il faut pas de quelqu'un
voit kate paiz là-dessus ce ça sert à
rien on s'en sert jamais mais il ya
georges est pas le mettons du show qu'on
s'en est servi soit qui est moins chère
maison juste pour bouger le savait mais
même moi ça met des changes
j'entendais rire hilary ramène le rire
si les gens voient qui encaissa riz bon
mais ouvre les micros ces grands juste
pour qu'on puisse entendre le tout le
monde m'a accepté puis à ce rapport des
fois on ne peut 3,4 et apprécions n'ai
plus besoin parce que le monde en fait à
whisky c'est vrai on peut les ouvrir
moi aussi j'ai le goût de participer
mais aussi le goût de fateh la fin les
scellés ou sa rentrée au bordel
[Musique]
elle me laisse à sa femme c'est une
salle défaut trop généreuse 1 à belmont
glaive un compte
calmez vous mais parce que tu te disais
même pour en fait pour pour l'artiste
oui ces couleurs sera le feedback mais
même pour la folie maintenant oui folle
tu dois être dans une folle de jeu par
l'impression d'être seul chez vous sans
nice va checker cet état peut faire
partie d'une collectivité je pense que
ça c'est ce qui a manqué beaucoup à tout
le monde mais je pense que oui les je
pense que tu sais si c'est le sentiment
de se retrouver mes deux sentiments qui
est à son envie tous de la même affaire
c'est dix fois où oui des fous en show
je me trompe c'est un enfer outils et
moyens chirurgie fait les requis fallait
que je fasse un genre des splits quoique
le qui est dans mon premier show j'ai
juste et m'avance insee payet 2 - où je
mets à genoux devant sept personnes qui
m'ont pen se déchire et montgueux la
dgos jusqu'aux mollets mais là je me
penche plus j'entends les ché j'ai une
chimay peintre mais cette soirée la
boîte à bleuets je m'en souvenir toute
ma vie n'importe quand qui au saguenay
n'importe quand quand je rencontre
quelqu'un qui me dit je t'ai l'est pour
les peindre abondé vicky son ensemble
comme jamais je vois ravi que ça
ailleurs puis
alma ion la petite salle qui est la
boîte à bleuets la grosseur c'est le
même propriétaire de la salle puis la
fille qui est la diffusion a fait encore
dream et pantalon j'arrivais chez ya mes
peines légères comme étant la soirée où
le régime est débile bobin ce qu'il faut
c'est clair c'est la dernière chaudes
larmes
c'est un dimanche on venait de faire
sécher au maton qui apprécient nous
autres on s'en allait pour traverser le
parc walt et dorment à québec parce que
on devrait le plus rapidement possible
fauquet tout notre valise les restes de
mon linge et dans le choc je déchire mes
peines lèche sur scène les guillaume
pinault qui fait la première partie à
l'époque fait que sera pas long feu
je veux aller chercher tes peines mais
il faut qu'il parte et rapide la boîte à
bleuets comme dans un centre commercial
il sort il fait ma valise
il me ramène une part des peines
beaucoup ce temps les tôles épaisses de
chérubins se déchire et puis ensemble je
fais comme ben le qu'est ce tu veux pas
d'autre journal est avec moi je fais du
temps mais finalement je fais un genre
de dix minutes ça aurait agit pas de
peine
j'étais tellement content c'est la
première fois que j'ai acheté des peines
chez h&m parce que moi c'est la dernière
fois c'est la dernière fois que j'ai
acheté les pelles chez h&m mais j'étais
tellement fière de rentrer dans du mari
jacques chez jaurès est un gros
activement pour moi
hier soir la gagne et rythment la vie me
rappelle que la déchirer une vidéo de
lenny kravitz en choquera gay qui john
cyclisme et jarjat des squats en faisant
sur l'autre guitry peines des chypriotes
juste comme son sac de quick direct à
quelques faits d'ici dix à jardy culotte
de cuir fait toujours ses shows en
peines de cuir qui peau de bébé commando
main
un vrai rocker mais des gens je
m'attends à rien de moins que je faisais
on a tous les deux fait de la natation
de compréhension le puy - année je
m'étais acheté un maillot de bain speedo
voit un face km sur sur ebay qui était
rouge puis flash etc à ce métier sauf
que moi je partais du 26 mai lieu de
compétition puisqu'ils connaissent trop
le 26 piges avec c'est du 26 et je
mâchais totalement piché avait comme un
chef de chant clos un métal comme ce
maillot c'est comme je l'avais acheté
sur ebay mais pas coûté cher
finalement avant les courses
mais comme ça vaut un maillot 250 pièces
couet compétition le ce qui va jusqu'au
genou qui le lave et le change
je savais que les prix aussi servir de
la tag il y avait la taille fine offre
qui était comme approuvées par la fina
affective mais c'était sûrement tags
en rétrospective ça voulait rien dire
quelque chose de bizarre avec ce maillot
olympien était serré il s'en prendre ce
temps le peuple
ok lester la finale du 100 m crawl puis
moi je me penchais tout le temps à côté
du bloc des pas pour me mettre de l'eau
dans le visage
avant mes courses crime au rituel des
compétitions
pis leur je me penche pilote danois io
fa ou mes deux enfants
dana reeve d'aodi de l'arrêt jusqu'à en
avant jusqu'à jusqu'à la tâche
enfin complètement puis cet instant
l'anarchie compétition s était d 1,6 et
des bénévoles qui sont les chronos my
traitement puis les bénévoles c'est
souvent des enfants du club école avec
l'eau
une tare parat fait que le machin fait
que dans le fond les personnes derrière
moi voilà le deccan balises la rep ou à
l'udc qui sort du maillot je me retourne
la mère est comme cela main sa bouche
les bougies bailout jeanny marc gars
comme ça je me paye même le regard le
logiciel qui venaient le voir ce qu'ils
disent qui vient de passer le relais à
un autre maillot mais je l'aimé vraiment
vite le jeu j'en reviens pim avait
attendu le maine et il a complété sa
main comme je sais ça j'étais sorti de
ma zone
non parce que tu es au lycée en natation
même quand tu es trop critiques étaient
trop près mais des fois tu n'oses tout
croche puis c'est l'adrénaline peut
donner c'est vers là c'était
l'humiliation totale a laissé sa chance
et surtout comme savons très bien que
c'était dans la position la plus
vulnérable montres au second la force
politique c'est pas mauvais ce que
quelqu'un ait un coût de 20 ça s'est un
peu froissé ça c'est juste un petit pet
époque c'est pas un enfant pas un
adolescent marc methot viennent de tout
repos c'est un cauchemar
j'ai partagé un moment mais si ça mais
c'est sec fait qu'est ce tu es hâte
d'être ici souvent on dit fallait être
là mais moi je trouve qu'ils sauront
leur zone
on essayait un peu de recréer ce après
ça les gens qui étaient là le sort qui
est cachée aux faits lui sont chers en
écoutant le show fallait être le piton
le raconte
c'est l'fun mais moi je pense qu'il a
pris quand même c'est effectivement ce
qui est tu dises
c'est ce qui nous a manqué été décidé on
en sent mondaine place puis à sword ce
qu'on va vivre
on le sait peu ça va être super ça va
être cool wei a sonné manquez pas ça
existera pas nulle part d'un serment ou
non leurs potes des serments net de
special netflix que le monde vont
pouvoir garder encore susciter one times
et c'est exactement ça sera un excellent
spécialiste des artistes qui se
déchaînent les peuples à sac le site est
pas la pandémie très longtemps même
chose bon ma première réunion au mois de
février
blessé à un genou ne s'arrête au moins
mars l'année prochaine aventure est
toujours le point exactement
mettez en même temps c'est vraiment une
belle affaire parce que moi ça m'a
permis de vivre encore plus d'affaires
puis des de ces dieux de changer pendant
l'opération sans arrêt ça pour ça 100%
îles d'or des jo qui marchent plus avant
avant la pandémie était de tellement
tellement gros qu'il faut ce qui est
arrivé que c'est comme j'imagine des
fautes pas le droit de te poses choix de
t'adapter ou de l'adresser dans les dom
et j'en parle peu partout pendant le
show en ce moment il ya paul un mot
pandémie et quarantaine ou allez vas y
je veux pas parler parce que chantier
dans dernière mais pitié partout en ce
moment par toutes ces idées je suis
rentré ici trois secondes sa mort
appliquée on est en pandémie on est
rentré on avait nos masques le plexi me
rappelle qu'on en pandémie avec si je
veux voir un show aussi je vois écouter
un film si je veux je pense que j'ai pas
envie personnellement mots qu'on me
rappelle se déclarer dès fois maintenant
je regarde des films puis même si le
film a été fait par la pandémie
le fait que touchent tout le fait qu'ils
pratiquent et des événements qui
rappelle qu'une pandémie fact et
peut-être que ma tante a débloqué hier
chez les ch pas les seules images aller
je lui porte avec un statut latine le
j'avais vraiment vous rendre compte que
la semaine passée c'est pas vrai qu'il
est arrivé c'est toute la semaine passée
le même bilan mais oui non je crois il
se dit oui c'est sûr qu'il faut adapter
des affaires j'avoue le temps pas puis
une fois ou jeudi il coupe qui vient
s'asseoir avec ma blonde de penser la
bouteille de même type il est fait que
christophe finalement c'était de ma
faute c'est juste un moment où on en
parle mais mais c'est vrai que wii fit
il faut s'adapter
on dirait qu'il faudrait que cette année
c'est comme si on s'était rendu compte
que les gens doivent s'adapter mais il
ya cinq ans il se passer je ne sais pas
quoi fallait tu t'adaptes ans mais cette
année c'est que le move est ainsi que
rien de mesures de m'adapter mais qu'est
ce que tu faisais quoi à 20 c'est comme
ça un pique nique d'or etc jamie mohamed
soit adapté afin de coincer mais non non
je refuse la température la température
steve
non je pense qu'il ya sauté mais oui on
s'adapte mal c'est sûr que c'est sûr que
l'adaptation est plus capital maintenant
que mais en même temps j'aime ça j'aime
ce que tu dis parce que parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup de tu t'es avec avec la
pandémie quand c'est arrivé et il ya
beaucoup de monde qui qui pensait on
devrait plus porter charlie sera essayé
de trouver des solutions mais ton chèque
s'est passée la drire le tuer
de trouver des solutions métiers sauf
que sauf que ce que c'est comme dans
tout il nombreux restos que j'ai vu
qu'au final évidemment y ont mis à pied
leurs employés qu'ils autres sont sur le
chômage maintenant mais qui ont réussi à
transformer leur bizness à faire de la
livraison à côté à transférer
transformer un petit peu leur affaire
c'est me c'est faisable
l'adaptation était faisable s'était pas
pis puis c'est peut-être une position
privilégiée de dire ce mets mais je
pense que ça mais je pense qu'il y avait
possibilité d'adaptation pis ceux qui
l'auront fait vont en sortir
ben plus gagnante si les compagnies mais
tant qu'ils vont réussir à s'adapter
comme du monde qui ressort puis que là
et finalement ils réalisent qu'ils ont
pu le loyer à payer parce qu'ils ont pu
besoin d'endroits sur place toujours de
mons en sortir gagnant au final de ce
tour le vois je pense qui est il dû
pousser va tirer de tout et puis ce qui
ce qui pouvait s adapte et qui avait le
goût de l'effort qu'ils avaient les
moyens de pouvoir le faire mais je pense
que les autres ils ont encore plus une
belle l'iss à laquelle ils peuvent
choisir des côtés positifs 6 mai
non c'est ce métier à prêter je sais pas
des fois je me pose la question
ok mais aujourd'hui losc et je voudrais
qu'on n'avait jamais vécu ce 6e pandémie
les skis je voudrais qu'on lie jamais
vécu ou au final ait quand même eu dit
des trucs qui finalement c'est en tout
ce qui y
il ya des gags le hockey ne réfléchis
mais tu arrêtes tu pries ce temps le
sait pour l'heure finalement aujourd'hui
c'est quelque chose qui foulent crucial
dans ta vie tu y mets ton du monde qui
font du télétravail typique est pour
piller des entreprises
mon frère est en jeu vidéo et
télétravail pour eu le seuil avance
abbey porte géant oui c'est charles
comme on dit
le nombre d'appels qui répudie mail qui
financera ce que l'on a appris que ce
meeting l'heure ça fait un email puis
être dans ses six mètres
on se voit vraiment si on ne peut pas
régler le problème mais aujourd'hui je
me dis ah yo rops a repris ce pour ton
laïquement ben finalement est-ce qu'au
final si on additionne toutes les sommes
de toutes les affaires
est ce qu'on voudrait palabres véhicule
jc pas la question
maintenant je peux juste répondait
personnellement de la société je ne sais
pas mettons de mon point de vue
personnel je pense que je suppose
c'était vraiment positif cet été à un
moment d'arrêt forcé de réflexion
d'introspection d'ajustement justement
qui au final j'ai grandi bien avancer
vraiment en plus ça m'a forcé à faire
parce que sinon je te donne plus tard
dans la même affaire c'est ça qui est
fait cui mettons un nouveau personnage
drake ou drake oui monsieur sûr c'est
positif le mécénat recentré sur moi-même
vraiment beaucoup lu j'ai fait beaucoup
de croissance personnelle dans
dans de rien et puis je pense que c'est
un bon moment pour le faire signer
d'autres j'ai frappé la trentaine
pendant la pandémie puis gros party gros
gros party en plus et en plus nous ce
qui se passait dans la pandémie c'est
quand je suis passé des mois sans borne
remettons le tdd deux mois d'affilée par
ça donne il y avait juste rien faire je
le faisais pas mais quand mettons ça
m'arrivait d'hommes en ouvrir une meute
ont quand même a fait le jouet ce que le
g20 ou avec des amis me conseille tout
le monde on se prend boyle
le ccac et john ashton cas et cela pour
asseoir les gens craquent une pelouse en
crack double outre mes amis ont comme
des blondes puis plus amener un par un
ils s'en vont le match tout seul dans
mon salon mais je manque ragueneau
depuis je les chapes seul dans mon salon
à écouter genre des vidéos youtube de
milliers trouvé cette oeuvre a été
et comme s'ils n'ont j'avais besoin de
te moquer j'avais besoin d'être seul
puis mémé tu vois ce genre de
d'événements le me rappelle la
différence en mettant mon parcours il
parcourt d'autres personnes qui sont de
mon âge que j'ai côtoyés longtemps qu'on
avait un parcours semblable jusqu'à y
mettons le ticket ce qui est je commence
à perdre
dans le fond c'est le fait que j'arrête
mes amis que c'était mes amis mes tondu
de l'université on a joué ensemble puis
a tiré puis éventuellement tous
étudiants longtemps lyon ils sont acheté
une maison sont en couple savoir au
prochain step puis moi je te seul à
danser sur du depeche mode à mon salon
qu'un que d'autres sont allés se coucher
jour dramatique compliqué ça ça me
permettait d'être à bord mais là j'ai 30
ans qu qu'est ce qui se passe là avec
son lot avec la situation actuelle de
moi qui fument un peu bas tant bien que
mal même si le ticket des eaux usées sur
ton ex mais remettons il ya peut-être
schiphol un moule je me sentais il
dessus mains habiles j'arrête qui gèle
peujard était belle de mai j'allais dit
souvent mettons de mars mars avril
j'ai beaucoup dit et merdad sans
vraiment su chi ben je me sens contrôle
de plein d'affaires sur les qualités je
veux exercer un contrôle puis la mamie
une affaire là où les communes comme une
espèce des fougères vous ce que l'espèce
des plaques d'équilibré sur un des
angles l'actif sur un triangle plier à
côté qui sait plus ça fait six points
qui travaillent fort pour essayer de
ramener les affaires des fois je trouve
qui est la journée où tu dises comme l'i
pour moi la journée 10 ans sur 1 x comme
une journée où tu trouve beau arrive le
temps des jo tu fais non aujourd'hui je
serais content d'être moins l'image
d'henri petit match
longtemps pilot qui fait qu'elle est
fait un nom
jacques chirac est mon maillot et je
trouve qu'ils éthiques
c'est quand tu parles de croissance
personnelle monde irait qui est aussi la
trentaine
si celle la trentaine l'homme le tacleur
grand trop entre eux je sais pas si
c'est si c'est la trentaine ou arrivera
mais hammami j'ai fait que mark était
juste d être content cette journée le
pape pour remercier quelqu'un ou quelque
chose mais juste de prendre le temps de
le savourer il s'est juste dit
aujourd'hui le savent a pris ses filles
six mois ça ait dans les jours où ça va
moins bien
moi comme toi même dans les derniers
mots semaine je me suis sentie sûrement
expliquions 10e place est vraiment être
oui il est impopulaire désirent se
rendre et que le déconfinement vielles
ruinés mais pas dans le sens que j'avais
comme un genre de nouveau be hasty kt
est impopulaire et contre la maison
métier de passes en 25 ans kim à la
merci mais non meetic dès que les couvre
feu jeudi je pense que la pause monde se
réjouit ce qui est peu de couvre-feu aux
mouches qui je vais aller me coucher
tard pour maigrir maintenant oui oui
c'est ce qui l'est c'est comme ont joué
à 6 eur puis à 9 ans quitte à rentrer
chez nous je me couchais qu' il y avait
peu je manquais jamais rien parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas de partis ou de tirage qui
saisit plan fin de semaine c'est comment
faire un show ils ont le droit place et
comment voter au parc du tout qui le
crie ça me tentait pas tardé poppy le
nom je parlais je parlais mais genre
j'ai eu parfois l'espèce de weird déjà
le juge plus blanc mais c'est sur le
couvre-feu mais ça c'est rien il ne faut
quand même que je fais je vous le redis
ça me tente pas j'accompagne un ebit de
me lever tôt pillés à s'écouler jardry
que couvre couvre feu c'est comme dans
s'entendent plus d'un livre en gage car
jusqu'à minuit 1h la descente en plus
grands succès
tu vas garder cette ligne directrice là
où est ce que tu penses que tu as tu
peur de retomber un peu dans le costard
pinscher somme à ses claques
le mode de vie était aussi les choses
soient ça va revenir le type à bord
venait c'est clair mais mes mots
d'affaires je pense qu est ce qui m'a
aidé et que j'ai fait la première partie
de louis josé pendant deux ans si une
tournée qui est pas coulée dans la
rocade
[Rires]
il est tellement ans mark allemand des
personnes et puis gentil gérant compris
mais je te dirai pas qui je pense qu'il
ya eu ces belles âmes et moi même lui en
parle tout son entourage ont pas mettez
sa deuxième tournée il appelait le world
tour puis la troisième tournée sur quels
mots j'ai été pendant un reboot
s'appelait le pape a tort ça lisait
beaucoup de biographies des fêtes
après un show on va prendre une bière
dans une chambre mais que ça va être
tout et puis à manisha en tournée avec m
j'ai presté qui qu'on avait croisé
quelqu'un d'autre on se ramasse puis on
est déjà tadoussac et puis on fait des
shows puisque main et ce festival un peu
du maupuy moi je suis le soir puis dans
les 5 à 7 c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui
dans le gers avaient été les étudiants
de l'école le mot puis tout
puis on se croise et l'amener sais je me
suis parti je pensais les grandes crues
mais je sais pas ce qu'ils disent et
après on se retrouve au banc
nous sommes allés manger le
renouvellement je sais moi je mange
après les shows c'est que vous avez des
trucs d'athlètes qui mange pas je peux
vous augment moi je peux pas manger 1
heure avant ça se prépare
je peux pas faire ça la gagne
côté qui m'ont à fond j'imite un espèce
de gaz naturel puis il ya comme rose un
peu puis je veux pas boire dans un verre
transparent mais je vais pas quel moment
dans salle fait j'ai cliqué bouzigues et
mon côté pourquoi j'avais foule dans
prévu à québec puis on allait super
après puis dans ce temps le moment chaud
mon premier show et vins en vrac puis
après l'entracte et on veut speller 90e
réservés je remballe figé minutes de
show en forme
jean ba et les crashs genre base de
sucre je suis fou l'étourdi j'ai fait 45
minutes de show en maniant un vertige
constants parce que j'avais bu de l'eau
mais je n'avais rien mangé j'avais foule
l'entrevue sa soirée j'avais parle à
quelqu'un au gym qui m'avait dit mais tu
devrais reprendre genre d'électrolytes
de truc juste du suc juste pour te
garder
puis c'est un monsieur comme naturelle
jamais ton genre de khan cheikhoun pis
ça va juste faire en sorte que c'est pas
manger une barre de cheklam et on ne
sait rien de transformer le médecin dans
l'eau ça goûte ultime en lopy pas de
savoir est ce un coup de com de loire
inscrit l'essai jusqu'à le truc devient
comme rose un petit paquet quant à sa
croissance
pff à quai
pourquoi s'éclater tête avec ça pilatus
et les grands crus qu'ils vont manger à
pêcher tout faire on va te tuer on va
aller manger après je vois pas trop on
arrive et le ont planifié il ya un doute
que des jeans parasco comme déchiré
lettre c'est raide ciampoli 2000 lui un
bateau puis aux clauses
il va nous a mené en bateau c'est sur le
fjord
ça va être malade qui leur est il faut
venir à tottenham là on va voir les
belles de nuit avec un doodle par atis
copé un vinaigre et chaud qu'on peut
vous arranger de coop vous embarquent
exo montait québec - d'adé lui 42
rejoindre puis il dit lidia marilyn
c'est pour nous est en tournée ces puces
spéciales et là le coeur fait au shit
moi j'ai trouvé ça dans un super bike et
deux quarts mais vraiment ouvrir de
faire ma demande j'ai un autre choix si
on sait vendre à toutes les choses qui
ont fini à quatre heures du match batum
financer un bateau et à part à ce qu un
type dans l'espoir
j'ai comme l'impression quand je vois
tout haut que moi j'irai me coucher je
pas sûr qu'il va être comme ben oui je
comprends vire d'abord ils vont franck
est simple que tu en gare aux radios il
veut c'est du coran ça va finir avec des
affaires fait qu il y avait cette
affaire le désirent
c'est vrai qu'il ya des soirées où c'est
fun for lafayette puis toute l'équipe
mais tout les soirs pour moi c'est
désormais demain c'est qu'est ce qu'est
ce qu'on va faire tes jeux d'ici là on
en bateau demain on va tu trouvé sa
plaque conditions fait rien ou de si
mais moi je reste important est de
mettre les tricots clapet de montmagny
de chomedey godard qui cause noble
ils savent que je vois à prague m je
prends une bière chaque mot vient quand
même c'est au trait jusqu'à temps qu'ils
m'appellent le père péter mais c'est
juste que je trouve que souvent comme un
scam et l'avenue facile de rire de la
personne qui veut pas venir ou qui veut
s'en aller tôt des plates titi fériés
bis fait comme buy in all thy
on est dimanche moi y est
on joue la game commence à 10 heures le
soir que c'était pas prof tout des fois
y'a un petit mais c'est que c'est le
travail aussi même c'est là que ça dit
un peu pernicieux ouais parce qu'elles
travaillent blend avec la vie sociale
faut que tu sois capable de mettre la
limite parce qu'un - postule le type
exact qu'on travaille justement ces
profs mais la limite est de 8 à 4 puis
apprécier les limites sont déjà imposés
se passe à l'extérieur c'est comme plus
tarder jamais fait que tu peux prendre
la décision que tu veux après midi 16
blend ensemble c'est dur de voir la job
comprendre viennent d'en prendre une
décision
des fois je trouve cette offre des camps
là dessus quand ta job c'est ses tapas
et on tire ma job c'est ma vie mais ma
vie faut pas que ça sur ma job
et puis des fois c'est sûr je trouve
c'est difficile à gérer je peux comment
vous ô vous arrivez à algérie mais c'est
partout dit elle on a pris la décision
de faire deux podcasts par semaine se
trouve cette heure mais tout du genre et
si ce territoire qui met break mais lui
en échange mais un peu de gaz qui te de
la quitte
des fois je trouve c'est difficile
d'être surtout mettons moi quand j'étais
célibataire
c'était de me dire je vais trancher tout
le temps tu as des choses que je veux
c'est être chine nous je pense c'est ce
que j'ai quand même une pensée pour les
gens qui ont vécu tout ce contexte seul
modal dans l'état où j'étais comme cage
lors de ma dernière rupture soit il n'y
aurait pas fallu que choix 1 1 chez nous
dans cette maison que dans deux maisons
le très précise et même glisse ça aurait
été impossible
j comme sombrer dans job même année je
me suis rendu compte que au québec les
cheveux travailler ses plats
donc les jouets c'est d'amener le parti
sa job mais d'un autre côté où ben
finalement 6 6 s'est plus rendue la fois
que j'aime le plus c'est rendu mon
travail puis comme n'importe quel
travail des jours ça me tente classement
pau puis mes collègues de travail j'ai
choisi pas tout puis le touch2
c'était j'aime plus des fois c'est ce
que je trouve difficile à venir comme
blandy ouais ouais parce que parce que
c'est sa fille nippone sinon si depuis
mais pas une fin et ça finira jamais non
ça c'est mettons les peut toujours
travailler plus mais toujours en
infectant qui décident de pas activement
dire non dit ceci offre limite mettons
maugis j'ai arrêté de répondre à des
e-mails après cinq heures et on sait ça
a été ta faveur
puis c'est encore aujourd'hui des fois
faut que je me force pour le faire c'est
mettons en fin de semaine dimanche
j'avais genre une j'avais rien à faire
les tiges des jarres une journée
vraiment volochine houle puis il a fallu
que je me dise non je réponds pas aux
emails tu réponds demain matin à partir
de 9h c'est là que tu réponds à témoins
le jeter comme en mode et qui jouent au
foot et le basket imagine le bleu du
club basque est petit ce ton ciel
pendant les pauses puis braindead un peu
sur hésitent à sauter mais j'ai pas
personne dans ma vie mais je trouve des
fois c'est qu'on est tellement habitué
d'avoir une réponse à notre question
maintenant tu es c'est quoi la capitale
était dit que son vote ressortira-t-il
d'acteur que l'on va trouver la réponse
maintenant je vais rentrer en contact
avec dit être toujours tout est correct
pour deux heures on s'envoyait l'adresse
à 50
je l'avais déjà si je lis vu que tu m'a
écrit bones a sa propre et j'incite sud
on dirait que le poète joignable
aujourd'hui on va embêter un pour notre
génération les générations futures
je pense que ça va être quelque chose de
binbin difficile à vendre
this day et
domitille maison non il va te rappeler
quand il va rentrer table parfait je
sais qu'ils vont me rend plus se
rappelait pas six points et les fiches
des textes qui m'appelle je réponds pas
du bon texte et je te réponds petit veau
mort texter se vend même si ta g et
permet de surfer baignade y est pas
d'autre option que image assez juste
qu'il en soit on aime tourner quelque
chose ça fait six fois que sa vie bat
d'un bon on ne sait pas combien j'ai de
mercer de mon équipe c'est ce qu'il m'a
dit c'est à ce prix là c'est deux
personnes vite urgent m mais non ça se
peut pas ça c'est sur la forme
moi j'ai commencé aussi à faire le week
end j'essaie dé foi de deux mandats les
dents normes en camping mettons le temps
à mettre mon téléphone en mode avion
puis je me suis dit qu'est ce que quel
est le pire qui peut arriver mais donc
maintenant le scénario le le pire
scénario d'urgence ultime ces mets ton
ta mère est morte
si je mets ton jeu par le samedi matin
et puis j'aime c'est la mode avion puis
que je la prends le dimanche soir le
savons pas changer grand chose dans
qu'est ce qui va se passer
c'est clairement un scénario
extraordinaire peu probable
ben non maîtrisables mais ça serait le
pire scénario que je pourrait manquer ce
serait la pire informations que je
pourrait manquer mettant l'unité fait
genre je peux la manquer de 48 heures
quand même même si la paire informations
mais a dit ammar qui ont sali moment
autour du goût est encore là son premier
spectacle en fin de semaine à tire le
coyote puis à mon texte et ariane qui
était la première partie j'ai failli
face tout chaud le pigeon j'ai dit non
je dis non bravo à cause qui on avait
plein de podcasts semaine leur faisait
comme je déplace sur toute une semaine
de podcasts parce que c'était comme une
résidence de cinq jours c'est comme cinq
jours deux ans pour monter le choc fatal
mais moi y avait trop la cueillette de
larochellière
d'ailleurs un mois puis à rien à refuser
toutes les cinq jours ariane water music
club entre dans le fond puis m'ont
appelé pour que je la bei spiez
j'ai dit non même prête avec toi plutôt
baiyun sémalens mais j'imagine j'imagine
il ya quelque chose que j'ai entendus
sur le fait un podcast avec de vie
bourgeois oui puis où est-ce qu'ils
repassent un cv important c'est
important dans ces risques il est quand
même cool concept c'est vrai il ya
quelque chose qui nous lie indirectement
ici on a lancé un podcast qui s'appelle
sexe oral une production originale
oui mais oui mais oui avec les en hadopi
joannie docteur point g grenier qui est
présenté par erreur ses compagnies mais
exactement ce que je mangeais sais que
tu sais parce que c'est en premier
league en humeau c'est d'avoir écrit des
jack pour les présentations à domicile
des races et compagnie c'est bon si
j'écoutais aussi jeter crampes et ces
malades sur tfou puis cette histoire
logique tu l'as déjà raconté oui c'est
vrai mais c'est vraiment une histoire
insein parce que toutes avaient pas fait
de deux premiers pas en humour encore
non à part les cours de soi également
ils t'ont trouver mais c'est ce que je
me demandais et les deux proprios ces
deux mois jacques puis j'ai pas
m'excuser à l'eau et on
jacques est blond piloterez les cheveux
pico c les clients à mon père mon pari
il firme de comptabilité keon tam que
ses ses clients puis mon père des
relations avec ses clients d'être dites
chaudes avec plusieurs de ses clients
dont les deux frères
mais ce n'est pas leur nom de famille
les frères près vous ferez vos acquis et
bine bine bine bine je sais pas mais des
fois il dînait avec les soirs ce site
géré par indirectement touche le doubs
monument est très content de
l'association du podcast mais oui parce
que lui il va gérer la comptabilité doit
il va falloir en fait en fait ton paris
comptant du confinement parce que le
confinement ya généré énormément bientôt
money exactement exactement mon père est
plus grands fans confinement et la
matière de la plupart pensent que je
pense qu'ils étaient payés t annuelles
par des skis et beaucoup d'îles double
vie que j'ai fait et dassault parc par
les années précédentes
mon appel disant oui je retiens cette
appli il y aurait quelque chose pour toi
ils veulent écrire des jo c'est satan du
jeu fait genre bah ouais dit qu'il
m'appelle qui m'appelle xavier nouveau
fait que je veux aller bosser à 4,40
la maison mère du baht comme le palace
la grève
là ce que j'arrive le filet belge aurait
encore des phrases par ce match j'avais
des amis et le m10 bon mais vient pas et
les chutes bacstor avec une madame qu'il
comme la gérante de jours les équipes
peuvent des équipes et à dubai
d'enfoncer si je savais cette école le
projet moi j'ai embarqué
oui je le fais et le ils font une
présentation privée
axel louis vibe
c'est ce l'autre les dauphins c'est sa
lettre des taudis cumulée soit et des
porn star
les fonds communs qui le touche à
s'appeler tiji chinois sans les beignets
avec ça inquiète qui roule à tout le
monde et je parlais nettement comment tu
es devenu un expert rapidement je sais
pas si je suivrai gains mais risquées
ces heures pile et je fais cette affaire
le et léger kribi jo je le renvoie en
effet 202 en 2 h dans le fond une chaude
pour passer la deuxième chaîne pelé me
disent ouais c'est vraiment bon les
filtres c'est vraiment drôle c'est juste
qu'ils aient on trouve c'est plus drôle
quand c'est toi qui dit choqué que le
délai hui des représentants terrassé
compagnie était papa - est clair délivré
moix volume au fond je vais à qui ça
dérangerait ton film ray lijo fait
l'erreur ces compagnies le mettons tout
faire et ici ça c'est à 4/4 en ait et
kick it site top bar du coin google
avait déjà vu ce trio magasin qui se
peut pas dow kokam plein
bon c'est dispo
yang et le proprio de l'édifice brûlures
et ac3 aac est donc celle plutôt la
carte 40 un viaduc ici puis juste là en
arrière se trouve pour de vrai les
centres de distribution des développeurs
rebours l'europe mais l'entrepôt de
projets crs et compagne de plein de
monde c'est vraiment un rhône et lettres
en espagne à un panier d'épicerie que là
ok j'ai besoin de temps de mais c'est
pour lui c'est pour lui les magasins
c'est le magasin c'est par les
particuliers
ce matin là est sûr qu dépôt est exact
et ses pouvoirs en publie donc
ils disent on va aller là dedans puis en
même temps nos notes d achat fort
facture entre la star peu comme le je
pense appelle le meilleur match que
prépares tu rentres ceux là dedans
ces pilotes mais tu mets ton panique
c'est vraiment rooney s'était jetée dit
c'est vraiment ce d'acteurs et dans le
fond tu as des salles avec des caméras
puis la salle mon enquête j'ai talent et
toute blanche la maille toulousain
sexuelle avait un sexe swing mais que
métallique tri que tu peux y ait est
clair c'est sa soeur paule tri et le
petit peu le maître en tabou city qu'un
pull à attacher la swing c'est que le
tout est attaché chine même jeté avec un
médium puis on ont fait le job au fait
les jo
celle là c'est simple et fismes pilori
mana centre c'est ridicule c'est foule
de la main et ont fait sur puis amman et
réseaux ils ont mis lyon fait un dvd
d'être car les gens devenaient
représentants des missiles se donner le
dvd puis mais tout cela ça arrive -
parce que je pense parce que marie j
-jacques je pense que ça serait tour
c'est qu'il ya le dvd de dette ce à
quelques pas lui mais qu'est-ce qui
mettons parce que avec nos contacts cela
retrouve on pourrait le retrouver le
sourire
mais toi tu es tu encore mettant si jake
lonergan de tout genre du beau jeu mike
et je m'en souviens pas de temps que je
me souviens juste deux jobs assure le we
vibe le oui vague site du brand schiste
on a fait ça vibre en fonction mais tant
de la ligne de bus lines puis c'était
jusqu'à mettre le ballon au fond des
filets blues tout tu te remets la rue
des bains culotte
ben c'est adele doha qui s'étendent à
d'autres utiles pénètre puis le terril
et ça va vibrer à sur scène
ils achetaient déjà à quelle belle façon
de découvrir diminue borg et qu'il est
assez crûment mais qu'il était d'accord
l'édile dolev s'en veulent acheter
natashquan
si l'on était les fessiers pilote avait
avant tout le monde
puis il y avait celle ci est déjà la job
steckel a simulé sur ces points-là son
nom de cheryl boire un thé mais c'est
avant qu'à s'amuser avec ce jusqu'à date
si c'était juste des aftis le buste est
faux le but c'était pas d'aller chercher
une classe folle la commanditaire iliad
il ya des représentantes qui trouve ça
difficile défaut parce que c'est un
sujet qui est peut-être pas vraiment de
moins en moins tabou mais pas pour rien
qu'ils étaient dr point g j'imagine ça
doit être la meilleure et je sais comme
celle là mais enchanté mais ça doit être
à qu'elles acquittent pas peut-être une
excellente vendeur ce n'est pas la
meilleure vente sur un projet se
connaissent eux quand ils écoutent
c'est pas gênant à n en pas mais je
pense qu'ils ne seraient pas prêtes à
dire que c'est tout le monde qui
finalement tyson et à l'aspirant le
monde a life plc vendre sa dette et 40
pieds ce qui a donc elle m'avait le mama
four pour le monde marc sens où elle a
connaisseurs puis après il expliqué toi
tu aimes couette de la foire peas eux
mais s'il ya une approche comique ça se
fait que ça fasse le même effet là
qu'ils ont leur façon que le lubrifiant
tu le sujet puis la clientèle à lui
remettre ça pour dire ok c'était seul
but c'était seul le but de l'exercice
puis et ouais mais c'est surtout leur
trouvera il s'y met
le tout mais je souffre au choix le 4k
samedi à lorient mais après ça peut pas
hype et a retrouvé le sourire
so you to be on veut le mettre l'été
comme si je voudrais très mal à l'aise
là combien sur dix que sally clés sur
internet le cv vidéo le bâti en même
temps c'est juste que j'ai fait et
couvrez ou jeunes viennent les pense pas
que c'est encore drôle je pense pas que
c'était à ce point là drôle est que dans
la vidéo là je dois peser 300 livres je
dois des cheveux longs jusqu'ici avec
des lunettes puis toujours et kahudi les
échos à l'idée que mentor mais pas que
c'est toi ce qu'ils vont me gêne ce
qu'ils veulent plus mais gêné ces deux
projets de loi seront plus que d'avoir
fait douter il dirait vue de leur faire
le si j'avais le temps quand même sujet
qui est drôle
joannie à l approche comique avec tous
mais non je pense qu'elle a même fait
les jours les côtes soit de l'humour
l'unafam à moi mais moi je pense que ça
peut être que bénéfique d'une vie puis
ma mère ma mère est prof de français
ma mère a man il faut qu'à parle devant
d'autres preuves pour que ma vie ici je
prenne un coup à l'école le mot juste
pour mercredi vers les cours soient à
l'école de l'humour il y avait des
conférences il y avait du monde qui
rentrent élèves qui dit je vais pas
devenir une mauresmo leur chute ici
parce que j'ai jamais parlé de l'an du
monde je dois parler devant du monde
l'année prochaine je vais faire une
conférence
j'ai juste envie d'ajouter des justes de
trois jo
mais quand nous mettons je voulais
rentrer à l'école de l'immo moi je
préparais des jo j'étais assise puis les
gens riaient
mais on riait autant à la personne qui
arrive et qui disait bonjour aujourd'hui
je vous parlais des ossements humains
donc les ossements humains clip l'accès
2 3 jo bien placé c'était un reer
méthyle le restant du temps j'ai déjà
mis à la mer esportsfrance com s'étoffe
pour moi mais sauf que quatre grandes
tadjau c'est super drôle moi je trouve
que l'humour tu sais si c'est un
excellent lien c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment le fond de jeu
c'est vraiment un examen des brillants
l'humour c'est l'fun mais c'est vraiment
si je n'avais jamais pensé à seulement
jamais jamais puis c'est sûr que si les
mots mettons les profs m'ont le plus
marqué c'est l épreuve qui avait un
d'élever un peu drôle de foncer dessus
il n'y a pas de faire une job par bourg
depuis que ce n'est pas encore super
monotone tout le temps du mois choqué ça
ici ça casse les beats accorde tout
répit c'est sa rente truc les formes
pittis as tu étais là pour apprendre si
tu oublies que tu es là pour apprendre
moi je trouve que c'est le sait le petit
va reprendre le plus tôt mais j'imagine
que non mais l'enfance ou à l'état
prétend du secondaire je pense que
c'était le goût d'apprendre le théorème
de pythagore à quelqu'un tu as une
panoplie d'options de rentrer sommes en
tête d'un jeune je pense que l'humour
je pense qu'un des lèvres il von des
lévriers pas ce qui est pas trop
scolaire le titre force couler dans vie
si c'est jamais bon disciple la
vingtaine impression de faire rabaisser
que ma maman m'a choqué ce qui va avec
des exemples d affaires des trucs tu
sais qu'ils vont ils lavent expliqué
l'eso tu as besoin de faire quelque
chose besoin de permission spéciale
ok tu veux te soutenons n'at-on pas
ouvertement à ton parce que ça va être
deux fois plus long qu'à t'en as fait
ton père c'est que l'hypoténuse
septfonds pas non l'hypoténuse est deux
fois plus long qui est légiféré doublure
plus jamais jamais jacques gérault qui
est vraiment le côté deux fois plus long
que l'autre une natte c'est un anglais
de rouabah qui écoute a besoin de ce
sport c'est comme quand tu auras besoin
de ce j'ai assez à des luttes musulmane
j'ai hâte d'avoir été toujours des
affaires dont il veut refaire sa clôture
puis c'est un carré parfait puis déjà je
peux dans quelle ville qui a des
premières j'ai assez hâte de tomber sur
une cour par maryse ans
le est incroyable lui a voulu il va en
fait comme moi je travaille l'hypoténuse
la gueule j'avais vu un même c'était le
guide est à tous les jours depuis qui
est sorti de ses gonds braille écrit à
sa prof de maths second bras pour dire
aujourd'hui j'ai toujours pas eu besoin
d'avoir une calculette
d'être capable de faire cela ma journée
puis genre à chaque jour y écrivait la
haye juste pour te regarde au courant
aujourd'hui j'ai toujours besoin de
justes parce qu'elle il fallait
cathartique détruit s'est demandée par
le ministre la met toute sa vie est
tellement j'écoutais j'écoutais dernier
podcast avec neil degrasse tyson
google a fait un nouveau pays il est
exactement celui ci tourne dans la
proche mettons pourparlers
d'astrophysique
c'est jean lumeau le pinard son podcast
à lui c'est comme celui qui plus comme
qui lui déjà faut ni mes yeux lui qu'un
humoriste le temps comme cette écoute ce
midi le monde urbain plus le good le
lendemain de réécouter parce qu'ils ont
rim ayant appris deux choses en même
temps que j'eusse comme des facs speedy
fille gentille en arrière de l'autre le
tamani c'est comme hello cet outil comme
chris boucar diouf et à profiter de mes
gains intéressants
moi je trouve que les meilleurs numéros
du mot télé numéro d'humour qu'on se
partage toute la gamme coincé numéro du
mot qui parle d'un enjeu de société
mais avec humeau qui fait qu'on comprend
c'est une mini rôle de dave chappelle
seraient les
jb tic plus une ride de chez moi mais je
te dis pas que c'est sens fort et je te
dis pas que c'est expliqué
kafi toi là dessus est ce que c'est une
belle entrée c'est comme l'acte ce type
cc numéro le qui veulent dire quelque
chose ici mais moi je trouve que c'est
ça il ya beaucoup le rire de quelque
chose ça normalise
bien que c'est comme norme c'est que
c'est accessible par un numéro sur x
games de la mécanique est
je veux rentrer chez nous oubliez le
couvre-feu mais une job frais qui est le
mien en tout cas je me tais dahmani
trouvera ndjock des camions faut
vraiment je rentre c'est le couvre-feu
depuis couvre-feu mois fédérer schirck
toutes les voies de tram études en
sciences ou pas dès qu'il ya tout ça va
te donner quelque chose
un allongement vos pauvres et appuie les
fêtes conviennent de rire on part sur un
rail à hiesse bakou c'est le fun d'être
vos bas et le monde ils vont des fois
s'ils conviennent de réunion pour rien
souvent on va chercher à partir sur une
claque ou à partie selon mr gag pour
finir sur ay c'était vraiment le fun à
prochaine ce finisseur trop plates ou ou
trop moralisateur se finit sur un acquis
c'est vrai petit lait le riz voudrait
finalement c'est une réaction
instinctive s'effectue sur sa joue sur
quelque chose dans notre cerveau il ya
quelque chose j'étais kicking dans notre
corps qui libère puis qui fixe et tu
finis sur un rail moins
c'est quoi les ce que les grands thèmes
mettons dans ton nouveau show un nouveau
show il parle beaucoup beaucoup de
parentalité vraiment énormément sur cd
sans même marrant comme concludes on est
ému chip à perm en it et puis et mais je
parle de mon désir de light l'epr kg de
vouloir l'être la seule référence j'ai
de la parentalité ou deux mais c'est mes
parents y est c'est pas quelque chose
qui est qu'on étudie pis je me rends
compte en vieillissant qui aiment mes
parents non plus n'avait pas étudié ya
point
il ya des livres le meilleur parcours de
qom et tout c'est comme il n'ya pas
sortir fait que je me rends compte
qu'elle est parent on se sont embarqués
dans quelque chose en sachant pas plus
que moi présentement quel goût de
m'embarquer dans quelque chose faite
c'est normal de faire des erreurs tout
le temps c'est normal de gc pas de la
manière que je sais pas si vous vos
parents c'était des gens qui s'excusait
de leurs erreurs mais j'ai l'impression
que les parents ça s'excuse mon image
c'est sa demande d excuses cobra 1,8 m
mais ils font peur
c'est bien pourtant mes parents me dois
faire des erreurs même dans vite et que
j'étais moniteur de cân gio puis à des
jeunes qui ont passé proche de se
blesser ou qu'ils se sont peut-être
blessé parce que j'ai pris une décision
de coop
oui ce correct on veut jouer aux acquis
et que la roche piloquet si la vie dans
les salles marc léger ventes de courir
pour ce que j'aime au sénat sens où il
ya des parents qui m'ont dit oui tu es
capable vas-y sorte dans l'orgueil saute
dans l'eau puis j'ai tout le moins il
arrive n'importe quoi mais des fois je
me rends compte que les parents
commettent des erreurs le soir quand ils
font juste mais la vérité c'est que
cette aide est chaud il dirait est fière
d'être remarqué que j'ai donné un
sincère coup de volant madd mais il
était peut-être un peu tard finalement
pour comprendre ta maison mais ils
disposent et méthodique tu fais quelque
chose c'est l'autre ce vote excusé petit
en vo dans ta chambre pendant une heure
ok mais j'ai dessiné sur le mur je
m'excuse si j'ai cette époque g51 savait
pas qui était dit ou là des crayons
dessine même outil m'a pas dit le des
crayons dessine sur les faits et opte
pour acquis que je le suis parce que
tout
trente six ans fait tutoyer ont
désinhibé fait mouche y loger des
crayons je me dis j'ai déjà vu mon père
met de la couleur sur ces permis
si tu crois que je dois t'y sa part yves
paquette
c'est chaud le parle beaucoup beaucoup
de parentalité puis en le réécoutant les
gels finch talent et à manger l'écoutent
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de cols sur la
mort vraiment tout cas déjà la lumière
au bout du tunnel puisque le peuple
affirmant tout même c-zéro un show qui
parle de mort c'est juste qu'il ya
souvent des décolleté jean mamie je
parle de dé mon passé le plus fort au
monde s'est piqué c'est vrai parce que
il ya déjà un mémo de l'école dix ans le
thermostat philippe était pauvre ah ben
tu existes lévis est moins fort
qu'est-ce qui avait fallu trois
intervenants du dîner qui essaient de
l'ouvrir plus c'est madame qui viennent
trouver la mort dans cette école
secondaire
c'était une vie remplie d'un job bd
s'est épanoui dans quelque chose puis
tolède à la retraite profiter du dur
labeur tu dis et si j'allais sur des
idées des frais pubères pendant l'heure
du dîner et jeux va être autoritaire et
que d'autres ils vont me respecter quand
non c'est toujours une madame qui
devraient très très mal à faire face à
ces défis font ils font le travail que
tu te faisais gérer les micros
j'ai vraiment beaucoup de fans s'étaient
métier moroni au chalet à saint gabriel
c'est des retraités qui sont là parce
que y'a d'or y adore travailler
il adore la construction beazize
n'obligerait chez nous en deux jours par
semaine je viens ici depuis sa des
besoins de conseils mais quand je rentre
tel cd v lui lui le fait le mauvais oeil
je vais partir des intrigues de parents
soient en cours pour mykid de quoi j'ai
besoin ce genre j'ai 17 ans jd tu as
besoin de pas de faire conseiller par la
gueule cette année avec le moule bah oui
la clé votre part t'as besoin de tous et
j'y mets plein de choses dans son panier
puis s'en vont je fais tout ce qui s'en
venait mais c'est ce que j'ai fait ça va
être ça va être ça va être un show de
naissance et de mort quand je suis homo
commun et comme secret ce qui est laid
cher je suis au moment où juste g
c'est le thème général la mare hâtive de
l'histoire je lis quand même pas mal
chaque liste que je fais c'est j invite
des artistes qui font pas de lui aux
armées voies le chou comme ram dam de
ces gens jetaient groupe gros femme de
malajube
puis j invite julie minot j'invite le
même homme qui sur le premier show que
tu vois le décor on les trouvera mais on
le trouvait ça reste que c'est julien
après le show qui a lancé quand il
parlait de la fin j'ai dit je sais la
fois la plus musicien j'ai jamais dit
mais moi dans ma tête en arrière fils
c'était mauvais ou vers midi je sais pas
pourquoi pas t'expliquer je veux dire ça
mais moi je voyais ce move over puis à
la première j'ai regardé remarquer et
puis j'ai des thèmes qui font de la
musique puis des fois ils m'envoient des
toons pitt image iso avec un ice me suis
senti mon objectif mais aussi du fric
est vrai que ce fut dur avait été fait
qui fait que c'est super bowl le mettons
quand je rentre quand les gens viennent
voir le show voulait en fin de semaine
passée j'étais à brossard paix à
shawinigan puis il du monde sont venus à
brossard puis à shawi puis je leur
disais hier phoque avec la fin si une
chipie timo je te demande à rien juste
hier fois qu'avec la fin puis seuil et
louis morissette est venu voir le show à
brossard et harvey bien dit c'est parce
que tu as faim parle pas de parentalité
si c'est ton problème ton dernier numéro
part d'une anecdote qui était en ski
d'outils comme ça aucun rapport j'ai
déjà hâte parce que c'était un numéro
tout seul et vrai à montfort mais je me
suis dit je le mets ta faim parce que je
veux finir avec lui non plus at il dit
moi mais pas ce seuil est super bon tout
seul mais dans l'ensemble ils détonent
tellement qu'on fait mexique le talent
est long par les tontons qui veut
peut-être peur que l'on parle de tout et
dance kids ou même à val d'or le sycot
l'est sera pas plus tu veux adresser
j'en parlais avec un autre artiste qui
est venu voir le show
les juges avaient enlevé ce numéro là
que j'ai dit je pense qu'un phoque avec
la fin j'ai dit la même chose qui les y
est arrivé il ya aucun poids qui est à
fond et pas vu pages avant levé numéro
du ski doo ça sera super bien mais leur
en enlevant quelque chose j'ai c'est que
les gens j'ai un quinze jeunes niveau 15
à écrire tout ça veut pas dire ok mais
d'autres vous venez voir le show ça veut
pas dire que vous avez la réponse à ma
question
ça veut juste dire qu'ils ont une
question pour toi qui vas te retrouver
mais des exactement de ces piquets tous
étaient habitués tout on est de tout
tout ce qui était en car tu vas faire
des choses c'est que tu es là x factor
tu va regarder ce qui est à la fois ne
sont pas posé quelque chose qui va fêter
ou peu tout quand tu vas voir des shows
thème telle affaire que tu vas peut-être
teddy hayes a passé ou à il ya vraiment
ce que je trouve ça bon et des fous de
monde qui viennent puis qui ils n'ont
pas de notes
ils font juste que c'était vraiment bon
même kultcha d'atik pour moi celle c'est
une note pareil comme décor et vert
c'est lui il s'est pas posé de questions
puis il se dit peu tel numéro ça clashe
et whatever moi c'est juste que ça m'a
aidé à écrire mais moi je comprendrais
mais le système en oui parce que quand
j'invite du monde a même cédé billet que
je vais pas vendre 250 personnes c'est
pas toutes les salles qui veulent c'est
donner des billets puis moi j'ai compris
elle mixe leurs tarifs puis elles
tiennent ici aimerait il aimerait savoir
que huit billets que tu peux pas vendre
avec des défauts je réagis tu as ouais
quand même les premiers mais bon je vois
ce 6g achète puis j'aimais au nombre de
personnes qui achètent des billets pour
l'humoriste déjà chez 2k
l'alcool absorbé titre jusqu'à joyal
dispo juste du monde connu lé métier
c'est très cool c'est attirer comme
comme méthode donc d'inviter de mon côté
que concrètement dehors de l'humour mais
moi j'aimerais beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de choses ont changé l'occasion
de pourparlers que l'artiste après des
fois je fais et j'ai pensé à toi tu
attendes ou non ces pièces de fond
raquettes et puis c'est mal il aymeric
guerre des mondes ou seniors
moi j'étais allé voir un show puis à
manier chez talea vend la totalité des
derniers jours j'ai vue c'est mon du
seigneur au moins début mars à québec
puis un mot avant j'étais allé chez eux
puis on avait foule parler les gens
ferment comme une heure et demie des
mises en scène des comment moi je voyais
ma forme et j'ai même pas vu son show
c'est juste des mots quand j'écoute
elton pousser les jeunes idées clés pour
fou qui met il pas obligé de vouloir
mais si jusqu'à malige d'une jolie
contact qui fait le chariot le fait
qu'il réalise ses clips
c'est à dire que ma chienne est superbe
et le cégep puis mon ma blonde travaille
pour le groupe de 900 puis fou qui
mengele faire une grosse colère cause
exacte mais c'est moche talent et
surtout ma blonde était succès qui fait
mouche d'aller dîner que d'autres qui
moyenne tonnes j'aime vraiment à nana
mike gaudet fou kitsch et j'en doute
jeté clip le foot ou le tourner au
chalet je t'ai dit pelé j'ai expliqué ça
veut dire tout qu'est ce que tu veux
dans vie mais qu'il te manque sur la
peau parce que tu en rêves mon chalet
laisse michalek a pas d'électricité
mon mon ponton est une terrasse
flottante même les bleus ça pas de ce
type sans assise je te vois la supplie t
j montraient des enfants qui n'étaient
que bouaké koulouba entier crie j'avais
c'était peut-être une façon polie de
dire heureusement ça c'est peut-être
c'était vraiment cool on en reparlera
mais bon je vois la conversation eu lieu
l'exacte
juste jazz et des artistiquement avec
d'autres artistes de tes projets de
leurs projets de wever quoi moi je suis
comme fantasme montrent bien qu'ils
voient filer voir dans un jour c'est bon
sur corner à la direction bad fils yvon
lachaud parfait fouiller la l'entrée
social l'alcool maintenant s'ils
rentrent un stylo la foudre j'avais dit
en tout vous êtes apte à garmin oui je
fais du sport
ouais ouais mais il était jeune qu'eux
mais en fait je le connais sans parler
de la môme on peut en fait je suis
régalé
et ouais pour faire du sport mais
c'était g lycées québec est la même
cetoula 7,35 haye et je sais qu alain
non je penche pour west ham 2 35 tout à
7 35 7 35 x très inquiet c'est très
riche
je pense qu'il a mis en avant dans l'eau
le web la vuelta à l'esstic vendée des
plongées
mais moi dans le fond ça montre la paix
savez si tu savais mais
moi je suis mega mega en actionnant
ville pauvre elle et shibam angoisses et
puis dans le fond c'est que j'ai juste à
cliquer un an au pij et m'ont fait de
savon mon pouls et défauts comme moi en
fait c'est les crises de panique ça peut
venir de plein de façons différentes
mais moi aussi je suis convaincu j'ai au
fond de crise cardiaque
je le jure qu'il s'assume artistes crise
piles et j'ai mal petits mots mon corps
ce qui est des fois j'ai l'impression
que ma taille strict et quand ça va mal
pour m'indiquer que ça va mal
physiquement mon corps fait il faut
qu'il ya un mal à l'épaule gauche
quand il sert son biceps et après les
pas les sentiments d'un cerceau là il va
comprendre qu'il faut qu'ils arrêtent de
dire que c'est un succès qui arrêtent de
trop fatale à faire au printemps puis
mot l'effet de juste donné un coup puis
de voir que kim a laissé bon le cht à
126 parce que je parle mais j'avoue je
suis heureux en train de faire le but de
cette montre le héli elle est réservé
qu'à ceux fabriqués et et oui je fais du
sport je vais aller courir le tibre et
j'ai commencé à et mais les chinois a
fait je me suis fait opérer au genou au
mois de juillet par magie quand les jam
était fermé mais j'avais le droit
d'aller d'un jim pour pharma terra
memoria petit j'avais mon papier du
médecin accès c'était cool facteurs qui
est leur métier comme le physio designs
sont remis juste et jambes quand même le
restant du corps suis plutôt pas mal six
mois tu pouvais pas rien faire fac
typhon mégi content j'étais chanceux
malgré ce pour continuer le match et qui
sait que maquiller les chevaux mon
chrono les cheveux calculé mis mes
courses mettant les pieds mais chaud
quelques méchants ouais mais cholet
tu dois faire des pas dans un chemin bah
ouais c'est presque et 4000 peu et dans
un show les foules chaud le camp gel
fear c'est presque deux kilomètres de
marche encore la droite mais marasquin
cash fait le full choi dur comme 1h35
1h40
mais là avec comme celle les couvre-feux
le fallait finir à 8h30 obligé moi je ne
prends bien parti
ça commence à 7
la star que ses revenus mais il ya quand
même des salles qui disent qu'ici tu
veux pas mettre dans prague faut que ça
dure une heure et demie parce qu'il ya
eu d'autres civique ou alors qu'ils ont
plus de vendre d'alcool
enfin que les autres une salle de
spectacle ça fait de l'argent que les
coûts du billet mais son bord vers celle
où c'est payant c'est mal c'est un
entracte de 20 minutes plus et 20
minutes où ils peuvent vendre la bière
qui dit des trucs demande fait que les
des fois ils vont nous demander fait 90
minutes de show parce qu'ils aient passé
se met techniciens sont en over puis moi
d'habitude ça me dérangerait pas qui a
et lover parce que c'est l'argent du
beurre qui volent et pays
elle s est vraiment une heure et demie
c'est fait des fois ils vont demander
semer facois l'échelle gel chef de
l'état à sanaa où saute ce genre plus de
kilomètres au bord d'un étang baobab
elle bouge moins 15 minutes mais mes
oies salle albert rousseau
est ce par large fakir salle barousse
tous et c'est un point qui est km de
marche
ouais vraiment les crises de panique se
faisait souvent souvent depuis longtemps
depuis toujours et dalphond tu vois
aujourd'hui je me rends compte que ça
fait vraiment longtemps que j'en fais
parce que maintenant je sais comment je
me sens quand j'ai quoi puis mois
exactement après le geste et c'est quoi
donc je fais à oui je me souviens je me
souviens qu'en seconde à 4 la veille de
la presse je me souviens en 2d barrant
la veille de mon premier cours de
piscine
j'ai assurément fait une crise de
panique c'est sûr et certain
la journée moi même j'étais stressée
j'ai pu j'ai pu en bois - fait mon
angoisse bien d'une anticipation
négative face à quelque chose soit fait
que georges prêtre en bourse à venir ici
parce que amman et lyon c'est écrit sur
instagram puis je t'avais répondu byte
mettons facture je me dis il m'a dit il
m'invite pour me dire que je t'aime
admettons cette fois aux personnes
toujours mais je suis non regnault
conclu
exactement
mais factice comme moi mettons c'est
c'est vraiment ce même ma première vraie
où on m'expliquer que ce qui vient de se
passer sans 2009
c'est le l'ambulance est venue l'été
puis les ambulanciers étaient comme ces
pauvres s c'est ce qui vient de se
passer si tu veux compte nous on obligé
de t'offrir d'être amenés à l'hôpital
mais si tu embarques aucun stress juste
tout le monde arrête au team c'est
romancé des cafés c'est dire à quel
point de départ fixée c'est pas grave
mais moi je vous dis je t'invite à venir
on va pas arrêter la menace en ski on va
pas on mettre au programme en plus
prisés on va y aller tranquille puis
battant bon 8 heures c'est un métal qui
n'entre plus on s'en fout le 5e si c'est
toi qui avait appelé ses partisans
si je me réveille je tends soir
j'appelle info santé qu'est ce qui se
passe l'épaule la maman c'est 2009
c'était l'école de l'humour c'est ma
première année à l'école ce thème
pendant mon premier vendredi qu'il sent
venir la première fois que j'allais
aussi que montrer piles si le monde
trouve pas ce bon qu'ils vont mettre
dehors il ne dit rien d'autre dans vie
puis je déménage à montréal pour sur
piles que si je fais ici
finalement c'est sur c'est quelque chose
que je me suis dit spin et puis lama
mais mon corps me réveiller dans nuit
parce que je dormais mes gueux léger
rumeurs exactement qui sont arrivées de
ses pieds ce gens parlent de cet
événement là dans mon show petit truc a
pas de savoir
la cause maintenant que cette année mais
ce que je fais taster c'est que dès que
je sens le besoin d'aller checker m'a
montré que le mettons j'irai les chutes
à 100 parce qu'on jose fait je serais
comme ok puis le out loud peu importe on
y injecte du monde connaît ou peu je
serai et je pense qu'il s'en mango
finalement d'aller faire le podcast
parce que man et j'ai répondu c'est
critiquer sur qui maillent plec équestre
a coûté mois puis me direz qu'on en
parlerait ou juste de l'avoir dit le
verbe à l'église quoi exactement moi ça
m'a aidé énormément mais c'est vraiment
depuis que j'y suis je comme développer
ce genre de technique l'ultime et ma
première et ma première nomination à
l'adisq
ça a vraiment été une des pires affaire
qui m'est arrivé dans ma ville c'est
super beau mais moi ça m'a mis ben trop
de stress à un point tel qu'ils étaient
jamais ce puma voiles illégales c'est
toujours super le fun mais ces mega mega
mega anxiogène pour moi vraiment j'aime
à l'inégalable j'aime c'est que les gens
soient récompensés qui s'y trouve ça
l'fun mais moi est en nomination c'est
que qui le si je gagne pas maintenant ce
que les gens autour vont se dire que
j'avais pas raison d'être nommé ace qui
aide les gens qui sont là vont obliger
fait qd extrapole mille scénarios
toxiques dans la tête pour qu'une fois
quelle raison et des fois je suis
megabyte avec quelqu'un parce que moi ça
fait deux jours que dans ma tête
on y ranger on veut se battre quand tu
seras tu vraiment le temps on se parle
tout cpo qu'il faut que je te dise
qu'elle est finalement je vais pas venir
au pas de casse mais tu en mets toi ta
tête monde le scénario j'ai reçu mes
tripes il a mangé en tabarnak la rancune
envers maxime et moi j'arrive filet je
t'ai dit eh ouais le papiasse forex en
part je peux pas être le plus titré au
québec la torpeur même watts on attend
peu dans ma tête je t'ai répondu ouais
mais je pense que je peux plus te tais
tu modique est ça coûtait du cash plaît
je t'ai répondu un match de repos puis
la nana
le tout on attend près c'est peut-être
hockey et mme livni
on peut tuer google books et un autre de
mes motos à temps pour le châssis ou ce
qu'on s'en veut facture je réponds non
mendouse j'attends rien qui fonctionne
ça sert à rien et oui les ti le tout
jeune de tata kim et moi je suis dans ma
tête depuis vraiment longtemps
ok ça arrive ça arrive et ça rit ça
arrivait fréquemment on le savait aussi
encore moins parce qu'ils étaient comme
ceux mettant chéserex depuis trois ans
ça m'arrive - parce que tu sais moi j g
skip potes de rencontre des psys parce
que tu sais que sam ait vraiment
beaucoup et que mes oies sa part vu sa
part pris de dessus jeter dessus de tous
bords et du monde comme ça tombe moi tu
me réponds c'est une fois puis c'est
juste que c'est fini tu vas y ait plus
aucune chute et parle avec toi mais ne
reste plus du tout est terminé je
réussis tu reviens puis si jamais mais
comme probablement et il ya une année en
particulier je le sais très bien qu'ils
exigent comme cette année le et
j'anime un show puis à la fin c'est
comme du dernier tournage
le producteur me rencontrer puis est
fait qu'est-ce qui se passe
triste et jacky study bonhomme a fait on
développe plein d'autres projets
ensemble
cpmic et ce qui se passe filet je fais
juste par kg comme envoyer sur dix et
puis dit que dans dernière dans le
dernier six mois maintenant je peux pas
dire que j'ai entendu des super affaires
sur ton axe mais en même temps
aujourd'hui c'est la plus belle affaire
comme on dit des fois aujourd'hui je
vous dis j'en sais qu'ils seront
exposées contre pige fait et textiles
100% contient de ce creuset de ce qu'il
faisait il se faisait tout encouragé de
kembs e s que le lendemain quand
quelqu'un a dit et il est vrai telle
personne n'a vraiment été de la marque
est ce qui est son entourage au fait à
qui on va y parler ils y ont fait de
belles heures non c'était pas si pire
que ça
et toi non écoutés coup de pouce qui est
la personne qui était maire commentaire
sur comment réagit on va nous en terme
de moyens pied à capote fac et elles ces
personnes le ps dise ah ben oui c'est
correct mais j'ai appris tout le monde
de travailler en laboratoire des
preneurs de son maquilleur la fille est
allée chercher graff délais légaux
requis le but qui allait porter les
cartes sd un coup qu'on avait fini
j'applique chaque personne ça m'a pris
deux heures et demie pas j'ai pris le
temps de jaser car personne que j'ai
fait juste à dire du comité mis au
courant le tipi dans le sens qu'ils
aient été mis au courant avec des petits
bobos qui a checké monbahus voir les
yeux si je peux dire seulement mieux les
jo où j'ai su que j'étais presse map
mais je pensais pas que c'était à ce
point la peau ce match je savais pas que
je trais j'étais très n'est peut-être
dans quelque chose puis c'était le goût
qu'on s'empare outils comme un aimant
mais c'est paris puis notamment pillay
aussi pire c'est qu'ils apprennent à
faire ça excuse pour trier ça peut
tenter de l'expliquer
et si tu veux qu'on se surpasse et ruby
je suis le site veut plus jamais dans
ses repas je comprends foule mais moi je
pense qui est aujourd'hui mettons ça me
tue borie je pense pas que ça m'a borie
comme indéfiniment 6éme et ont jeté
réponse puisque dans je sais pas là dans
deux mondes dans le temps après j'ai
refait des peu comme physique avec tours
et puis je viens de boîtiers pas été
créé je trouve ton numéro de celle çi
t'appelle je t'ai dit j'ai juste dire
telle affaire parce que tu vois que tu
devrais invités peut-être que ce mot là
aussi tu veux que je te dise mettront
encore on garde l'hypothétique de la
situation la seconde que tu m'écris sûr
je prends mettons une heure où est ce
que je fais comme c'est plate mais j'y
repense plus jamais je penserai plus
jamais ça se situe exactement mais pour
moi mes tantes et pour moi la lamendin
arables et est complétée qu'un jeu taleb
obligé elle sait qu'il ya des gens qui
est on le sait il comment une fracture
il ya des gens que j'aime énormément que
je considère comme mes amis j'ai ainsi
qu'une fracture fait tout pour réparer
ces saisies quelque chose que je fais ça
s'appelle cc c'est ce qui s'appelle
vivre avec les conséquences des cdc
geste seppi pour moi les deuxièmes
chances justice et a parlé je crois
foule a vraiment beaucoup mais il ya des
gens qui il y avoir des gens aux cheveux
mais si c'est le maximum que je vois
litre lüthi je pensais pas que c'est que
non non tout est bon
l'exact puces pour moi l'explication de
succès après trois ans de travaux
avancent équipe
des fois les gens sont ils sont m
ils sont marrants dans deux autres qui
les fait que je t'aime pic avec touche
pas être vrai mais je peux te montrer
que ça va pas bien mais la manière je ne
sais pas comment montrer que ça va pas
bien je
ses poches j'ai passé tafer le gpo les
epci ou j'ai pas des chevilles je n'ai
pas nécessairement d'une famille où on
se parle de nos émotions maintenant mais
je ne sais pas comment on dit je ne vais
pas bien
moi tout ce que j'ai vu dans ma vie
c'est quand quelqu'un va pas bien il a
agi comme ça puis des fois quand je vois
justement la dernière année des fois je
me dis il ya des gens qui démontre la
mort comme ils ont appris puis
municipaux correct ça ok il ya peut-être
une portion au moins j'ai envie qu'on
commence peut-être à la réparation après
commencer le tice comme une borne
c'est peut-être le tir de me dire il ya
des gens qui expriment leurs malades de
la manière qu'ils ont vu que de la
manière qu'ils ont appris puis on ne
vient pas toutes du même milieu l'ont
jamais vu ou l'ont jamais vu jamais
appris puis ils sont allés avec quelque
chose tu es puis s'étoffe de parle aussi
largement s'est largement lettre si
j'aurais envie de nommer des noms et des
affaires mais j'ai créé ce moment pas
envie de montbarnier la bande-annonce
humide mais il ya des fois où je regarde
si jean-luc je fais quand il beaucoup
beaucoup d'empathie pour ces gens là
parce que mes petits même le thé
qu'ailleurs eu plein d'affaires moi
j'irai texter ce produit par le pij est
fait pour vrai test serait peut-être je
vais pas au probablement parce que ça me
tente pas de même penser que j'ai la
dame mais peut-être épidémie dire comme
tu m'as peut-être sauver quelque chose
c'est que messi va être reconnaissant
comme toute ma vie c'est bon la wake up
call back souhaite rotor isaac onu
rachid sic on a parlé de tout ça c'est
que we say you wake up call
vaincre ici à ôter lui-même avant qu il
avant de se faire happer par le ceto de
l'huile se dit il le réalise et pis
c'est quand tu as rêvé toute ta vie je
sais pas si tu en rêvais toute ta vie
des temps aux mets ton était moins
mettons le mit jobs étudiante là je
pense pas que jamais que j'ai eu un boss
qui étaient comme à ce point l'iphone
parce que probablement que lui des
jeunes de 16 17 18 ans qui possède un
magasin grande surface
il était comme tout dans deux sites
offrent deux ans est excellent je voyais
ce matin tout dans un an c'est mehdi
monde passemar des d'obliger de débattre
avec avec madame d'une pharmacie pour
avoir congé la frontière de ta fenêtre
puis de faire quasiment faire sentir mal
de vouloir avoir of la journée de taf et
puis c'est passé travaillé tout seul
club
ben oui mais en même temps on s'entend
que je dis si tu pas j'ai besoin
m'acheter du oui pour arrêter aussi le
très beau métier multiplient la horde
work
je le fais beaucoup à l'école puis j'ai
de la misère - map mais tu sais pas à
quel point je mets beaucoup de temps
l'avenant avec moi quand je vis ici
placide des rouleaux de papier toilette
sur un étage heures je suis pas
reconnaissant qu' mariage et mais la
journée ne m'a fait ça se peut que ça me
tente pas de farce puis là je te le
demande un mois d'avancé tu roules les
yeux puis c'est comme si je t'avais dit
j'aimerais que toute la famille paye
pour sa part rapporté donc des fois je
me dis qu'en mouche voight
assistant-gérant mode c'est de la merde
avec les gens en dessous puis quand moi
je vais gérer votre su agir si jamais
été géré en y assistant gérant de ma vie
mais quand je vois l'ied je veux agir
pareil comme les gens auteurs des des
acteurs producteurs
animateur chanteur wherever qui était
pas cool qui était pas ce match il y en
a beaucoup qu'il y en a eu énormément
puis les gens qui commencent sont
peut-être je sais pas le thé est ce
qu'ils se disent c'est comme ça qu'il
faut agir parce que moi j'ai été
longtemps assistant pour admettons
qu'ils ont parlé de même pu vivre
c'était comme se plaît j'ai gravi puis
dans ma tête c'est comme ça qu'on parle
un assistant pro depuis toute l'équipe
mais je pense qu'ils auront un cercle
bien sûr je pense à un cercle vicieux
quand je sortirai rapport par
l'éducation puis par justement une prise
de conscience collective comme celle
qu'on a en ce moment le train vers
voirie en paix tant aux crises ça veut
pas dire tous le droit de toute faute et
se pisser ce me semble
souviens toi quand et hambourg se
traitait tipi qui nous mettons à
c't'heure quand j'ai re la position
mettons d'animation mais mon entourage
c'est que vous devez pas avoir peur du
fn cela qu'il ouvre cette personne le
pit s'est tu t'excuses faut que tu me le
disent parce que je ne suis pas à l'abri
des tipis je pense que ça va être mon
combat de ma vie
notez que tu en auras un conte but en or
mais l'ami ga sexy c'est le mien je sais
que ça va être
il faut pas qu ai-je les faux papiers je
laisse ma vie devenue ma job puis ma job
devenir ma vie j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de
misère à faire ce qui est mon maxi était
lié à venir au podcast dope doit pas se
transmettre d'un dans le car avec mon
équipe de tournée puis mon anxiété face
à mon équipe de tournée de poids se
transmettre sur la radio puis mon
anxiété d'une chronique à mal et à radio
de bosses de la radio qui me dit aïe
vendredi prochain est barbu nord avant
j'aimerais ça te parler ben faut pas que
je laisse sur la preuve il faut pas
casser sur la paire semaine de ma vie
il faut pas que chaque personne que je
peux rencontrer qui mettront en ce
moment une super belle rencontre
si on n en perd semaine de ma vie ce
sera une belle rencontre il faut pas que
je laisse ce de venir s'immiscer ça va
être mon combat c'est quoi tu me dis
d'autrefois et de commuer vraiment
d'économie réseau qui est arrivé je me
dis on engage des lieux qu'est-ce qu'il
ya des désirs et ses chemins possibles
de verdi le let go your mother et de
classer les 3 et 4 mai
ben oui il ya des souvent barré mais si
tu veux ça c'est s'étoffe laisser-aller
des affaires puis de ne pas mélanger
tout puis deux pas de reinecke 3d à fort
ya de quoi qu'il ya de cocadi ben dis
c'est pas le cas ça me rend marque et
ses 6 4 une position et ont privilégié
ou de pouvoir maintenant un certain
statut tenant ce soit c'est un supérieur
un autre où justement tu es étaient
connus et reconnus - foutu fasse
l'effort
conscient de ne pas utiliser ton
privilège mais c'est parce que c'est pas
juste de ne plus rien c'est juste rien
ça s'peut dans la tribune dans ce cas
dès que tu utilises ton le pouvoir que
tout sur une personne ou dix ans soit
l'admiration des fans ou que ce soit le
fait qu'ils étaient ôtés reconnu puis tu
peux parler qu'au pied tête intouchable
fallait fort consciente histoire c'est
pô juste pas juste parler toute bonne
personne ça se fait c'est comme c'est un
check up le dessin est ce que vraiment
j'utilise paul est ce que vraiment le
jeu mais je ne passe pas un peu plus
être qu'un autre je me pense pas tout
permis ou sous ce ces deux races pose la
question de savoir vraiment demander aux
autres ce que rec si je te demande
d'être fatale enfin c'est quand il est
arrivé avec une avec une diction lieu
d'un homme fse c'est comme ces mots jany
des ti des gens que j'en raffole
mais des fois on est dans une situation
de gestion de crise
ddd peu importe le double bookingdooh
peu importe quelqu'un s'en viennent
faire des choses notamment ben il ya des
fois où je fais ok qu'est ce que vous
avez le goût de faire ce soir
dans ma tête c'est clair qu'il faut que
ça soit moi qui fasse telle affaire
trouve de façon plutôt foot face sauf
que je veux tellement pas être les
petits boss kelly fois je fais arrivons
à ce que le taux l'autre
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire me
refaire pis elle propose en bas et je me
dis ça se peut que ça soit moi qui fasse
peur même si je pense que je serai plus
je serai plus efficace le mais des fois
je me dis le
c'est pas ta crise on est on est là pour
t'aider toi qu'est-ce qu'est ce que tu
veux que je fasse ses lignes même si
c'est moi qui qui qui emploie ça veut
pas dire que c'est moi qui ai le droit
de veto c'est des fois ci c'est ce qui
qu'il faut se rappeler des fois tu peux
laisser la la la situation manger la
raison c'est ce qu'il faut pas qu'on se
fasse avec le stress de feuilles des
situations qui sont somme toute dans
l'absolu bas la victime précise comme si
cela jour de plus importantes au monde
ou si il va arriver la pire affaire si
tu es aimé ton plus jeunes 1
des fois je partais ce métier m'a offert
un show quelque part qui met ton juste
entre sport dernière minute
georges comme limite clame et on fauche
l'autre mon stock dans mon champ
pilotage et on attend que je n'ai pas
ramassé plus je me tiens une fois c'est
sûr que ça fait plusieurs fois que ces
braves âmes 6 au pire je vis de mes 30
ans paul baysse médecins puisque comme
fuck faut que je parte pour mon show
plus et comme jean-rené justement dans
les parents qui m'a aidé à l'eau des
monstres mon stock d'anchois parce que
c'est un joueur templeuve
je stresse tout le monde le plus parle
beta tout le monde par leur aide à tout
le monde parce que je vais être top
c'est comme si l'avertissement semailles
et que la pire chose au monde c'était
mon ex avait amené genre tu peux pas
stressé tout le monde autour de toi
parce que c'est un stress inutile pour
faire vivre tout le monde
pendant cette période le tout le monde
était comme à qui on a des hommes
politiques à l'appui nous parle bas et
lourd pour moi c'est ça il faut les
aimer ton six mois mon maxi et et puis
mon angoisse c'est de l'anticipation
pour moi le stress est une réaction à
quelque chose qui le des fois quand le
monde y vivre vis le moment présent
pour moi le stress peut être plus dans
le moment présent parce que je réfléchis
pas tecan réaction s'il ya du monde qui
serait si fij
tout était dit ceux ci s'appuient by
pitot était d'une autre façon de faire
mais le défaut tchèque du monde qui sont
tout le temps gentil je fais que comme
en fait ces autres les champions tout
léger l'impression que chaque nuit cteur
est une douce lui de réparation tandis
que tu es capable de t'endormir sans
passer par un bang 45 minutes agnès rixe
s'est passé aujourd'hui où quelque chose
à faire demain tu te réveilles pas
fatigué pourquoi cette épice pas se
trouve le bon fait des clubs au monde
qu'ils étaient capables d'en parler de
type humain nous mettons ce c'est ce qui
m'a le plus plu qui je pense aiderait le
plus les gens c'est de dire comment tu
te sens maintenant c'est j'enregistrais
ch
je vais être en retard je vais stresser
je vois de la mode du cégom juste mais
oui c'est que des fois tu dois être
commencer de la marque puis des amis
proches qu'ils savent à qui peut dicter
tellement belle et vont ils vont te lire
et je les dépose le jeu ne me parlent
correctement je leur prends qui sont
parqués comme teddy tantôt dans cinq
minutes j'y pense plus à chalon mais de
ma vie c'est sur la forme c'est que les
menus que tout est dans tes d'arriver au
game et ample tu veux que tout le monde
est encore en train de boire leur café
et thé hop le guide to set up tout le
tout les chiffres depuis que tout est
comme je place taghit depuis le monde le
temps après quelqu'un d'autre
1 le turban il faut que cet arriviste
scénario lecoeuche comme georges vient
de vivre une heure de calvaire dans le
trafic dans mon short car qui pompent
j'arrive cinq minutes en retard tout le
monde et ben relaxe personne me dit si
sa soeur ya eu aucune conséquence j'ai
juste décidé de me sentir comme damas
pendant une heure ils trop stressé
existait pas de sa saison mais tirons ne
reçut j'en parle souvent la main ont
reçu une fille s'appelle sonia lupien ce
podcast genre c'est la cité dans la
liste et laisserait son héros sans cycle
qui tiendra
plein d'auteurs à donne plein de trucs
sur justement apprendre à gérer son
stress puis c'est quoi le stress pitch
pis elle explique aussi que le stress
est contagieux mais petit puis méthode
c'est maintenant donner l'exemple de thé
des parents qui rendent la job qui qui
qui déversent leur stress sur les
enfants c'était même si l'enfant y avait
plein d'enfants qui tue vivent pas
lui-même de d'événements ou des choses
tressailli ya cumul du sud finalement
c'est il ya des enfants qui part en
fumée
bref ça sent la même affaire ce plateau
de tournage dans un rebelle que ce soit
celui canaille inquiets ultra précis que
c'est quand même quelque chose qui tire
à l'ambiance de tout le monde plus tard
du pied moins agréable bien pipi
inversement des 17 ou désherber ans de
travail ou est ce que tout le monde est
tellement relax ça fait seulement du
pilar del marmol s'est comme c'est le
fun d'aller travailler puis si tu es bon
tu mets ton doigt sur 17
et puis des fois c'est long le matin à
voir exactement comment spa tournant 10
va tourner une demi heure après sa brève
du nord parce qu'on vire les caméras de
bar club reçu au final on va aller dîner
moi j'ai tellement habitué des le show
est à 8
j'arrive à 7 - corps ou autres sites -
core i7 et core je fais le show le show
fini à 9h30 de 9h30 jusqu'à et 35 chez
morrow après c'était intègre à ses
visités mars oui mais oui je rentre
efficace d'un enfer je ressors elena
outils puis des fois c'est tellement
long qu'il franchit même panier marc
mollet mais ton froc à quelqu'un qui te
file un coup de main wise as sommer vite
faire un tournage lui même je fais comme
parfait faut que je puisse venir
quelqu'un puis j'appelle un médium wever
aujourd'hui ta job ses cages
car ça va être long faut te rendre sa
pop là juste en étant tous en même temps
ou bien les jeux mais s'est racheté une
switch même date les tests des jeux
vidéo mais seuls ça fait juste je pense
le temps avec des fois il ya trois ans y
est
c'est beaucoup de chacun des mario kart
est content dit compte sur le frère de
daumier fait un film qui s'appelle nadia
barfly ses crimes sur la natation puis à
pierre pierre rives 15 à 10
j'avais un mini rôle dans ce film le pij
a amené fallait que schumann à une place
pour un gros soirée le tice a commencé à
5 heures puis ont une sortie à trois
heures de la nuit au pied puis arrive y
étaient là bien quand on est quand même
un bon une bonne santé ou est-ce que lui
devait haïti
sauf que ça paraisse et que c'était
parce qu'il n'était pas son premier
tournage parce que qu'un qui tournait
pas c'était le premier à jared belle
housse dans un divan parler au monde
parlait aux textes et aux figures à
bichkek et fusionnant avec toi tu fais
de la natation et puis nous on est là
dessus de n'importe quoi hull trop relax
puis il y avait tout le monde était
qu'un bon mais c'est quand conséquent
niveau puis lui ai jamais posé cette
question là une fois les ces justiciers
nuit jusqu'à ma journée le fait qu' ils
vont me dire qu'un choeur besoin de moi
sinon je suis juste un mode chill axe
puis y avoir balancé lui avait compris
ce que tu dit leroy cain qui m'a dit
quand quelqu'un passe dit miller à faire
quelque chose non utilisées qui est un
peu étonnante avis le pensait peut-être
passé dit miller a été en gros si oui
parce que c'est un pro de langouët l'on
mêle on va peut-être beaucoup ta
rattraper pour être devenu un produit
zen pro de la famille travaillons là
dessus
arrête de rajouter des attentats banques
des ces commentcamarche l'estrie amber
riley arrête tes jetons well efforts
actifs de travail et l'autre à fond moi
je trouvais tellement que c'est une
belle phrase cdm disait il dit douter
humoristes comme étant à était humoriste
dans ta vie je peux vraiment longtemps
betty dans ma jeune carrière mais du
tout chez que j'aime chez qu'ai-je fait
chier comme enfant puis 10 est-ce que tu
serais capable d'empêcher ou de penser à
d'autres choses
je fais comme
oui nous mettons sont si j'avais deux
bouchons dans le pré c'est un show puis
l'autre pour être énumérées une recette
easybike défaut quand devrait également
être bon dans l'anxiété que tu devrais
focus et à deuxième bush était calme et
tu vas voir que ça va descendre
j'étais gens comme ba c'est plus facile
à dire qu'à faire mais ce que c'est un
beau défi
c'est un travail ont vraiment tous les
trucs de trouver ben c'est sûr qu'il ya
des méthodes de respiration si ça marche
en full tilt ya comme je mets fourre
tout le temps d'un nom mais je pense que
ces cabas l'apathie façon drôle c'est à
faire le métier en acte c'est juste de
souffler avec ton diaphragme président
et on sait comme oui je le fasse les
meilleurs djs un tonton bdm tous parlent
d'anti force pas pour pour respirer se
laisse ton ventre gonflé ce comme une
autre sorte d'art en fait c'est juste de
changer ton attention mental ça n'est
que sur l'acte ce n'est que du foie qui
suscita respiration puis de la
redescendre c'est de la mer monte à la
menthe plus monsieur barroso mais ça dit
je ne sais pas la plèbe en poche ou non
l'état soit 109 sur le deist descente on
était capable de jouer avec tomber
cardiaque
donc tu es capable de jouer avec leur
esthétique comme tu dis c'est d'amener
ton focus ailleurs mais ma pauvre l
affaire qui marche le plus c'est à mon
jeu pour virer de bord aller chercher
maman aurait pu voir que met-on passé 20
minutes de détour je dois vivre avec lui
mais non je vois revirements comme ça ce
point l'homme mais la dame aux côtés des
fois je me dis ça serait une bonne
journée dans moins de cela mais pau
parce que ça
vous êtes une béquille c'est quoi ça a
plus de batterie lire ici d'essayer de
trouver d'autres trucs mais je suis pas
un fan du changement vraiment pas fait à
moi le chargement doit être progresser
et quand même somme toute facile la
trajectoire
moi je dis ça reste oui j'ose un objet
de la charia foule pas de comptes à ok
garmin qui a changé je pense qu'une
monde faut qu'ils gèrent charge jamais
bien site j'ai fait faire tout les jours
de se dédire
ben ouais ce que les gens qui nous
écoutent ils vont sur ton super bien en
ligne sur le temps de ploguer exposeront
surfer droit point c est dans le fond et
c'est sur toutes mes dates sont là sinon
ben rubin la plage bah oui quand même
s'est il ya quelques chaudes c'est
qu'ils sont soldats mais les shows
complets cd chaud que ça fait tim et ont
un arc en rêve quoi piquer c'est dieu
merci les gens ont décidé de garder les
bio le de se faire rembourser
puis progrès je le dis à chacun à chaque
fin du spectacle c'est merci d'avoir
choisi - de venir merci marc bol d'or
choisi mon spectacle mais pourrait juste
de savoir qu'il ya du monde qui vont
installer spectacle c'est la forme la
plus répandue juste de voir que la
semaine passée j'avais une journée off
puis je me suis dit je vais au cinéma
beaubien
il y avait plus de places s'étaient
plaints par la suite biais le tirage je
fais ça l'fun de voir l'engouement des
gens tipi mois fin de semaine chez temps
chaud à shawinigan donc je suis pas allé
dans une terrasse parce que comme
montréal on a on est encore rouge le
switch est pas riche de soldats
l'interdît et léger bocal podcast va
sortir magique quand ils sortiront pas
de quoi il par exemple
venez oublier ce n'est mais faudrait
être c'est juste content que sa retraite
ifa qui est très cool c'est vraiment
vraiment bravo pour tout merci d'avoir
écouté ses podcasts jusqu'à la fin de ce
pas que vous avez apprécié la
conversation ça prouve que vous êtes de
réelles fans de conversation et du
sans-fil pas de casser on vous remercie
vraiment beaucoup
si vous voulez voir plus de contenus
plus de conversations sur pétillante que
ça se passe ce qui est sûr peut tuer a
non seulement on met tous les podcasts
en ligne au moment où est ce qu'on les
tombes donc on a beaucoup de semaine
d'avant sur le pétrole mais on fait
aussi des encore moins de filtres qui
sont exclusifs au monde pictural ou est
ce que on parle d'homme nicole et moi de
la conversation combien d'avoir parce
qu'on met un peu plus en profondeur dans
certains sujets qu'on voulait aborder ou
qu'on a abordé pendant le podcast donc
allez sur une page de turenne les liens
vers ses avoirs dans la description du
podcast qui remercie encore une fois de
nous avons écouté jusqu'à la fonte